Yes,
live ladies and gentlemen,
this is a,
if you tune into this podcast and you're like,
ah,
this is a regular podcast,
right?
This is a UFC recap.
So if she fucking hate the UFC,
you'd be like,
Ooh my God fucking hate UFC.
This is not,
it might be the podcast for you though.
Cause we don't know.
Like we might start talking about the UFC and it might,
it could go anywhere.
It usually does.
These podcasts are like bike companion.
We,
you always tell them that it's different and all that.
But all the podcasts,
the last fight companion,
we only talked about the main event for like 30 seconds.
Exactly.
Rest of them were talking about everything.
Sex and drugs and fucking friendship.
Then when it goes to decision,
oh I got Dario Shit.
I'm fucking,
and
I watched that UFC on Fox.
Oh my God.
What a fucking card.
First of all during the on it podcast.
Oh you guys did a fight companions.
Oh that's a great idea.
People are doing that.
Other fight companions like other podcast.
Awesome.
Why not
girlfriend Alex Jones did it.
Yes,
they're amazing.
Alex Jones was on doing a fight companion with Aubrey and that's amazing.
Crazy.
God.
Damn,
I got to listen to that now and we'll go back and listen to that dude.
He is so impressed with,
you know,
cause we knew Aubrey before on it,
and to watch him blow the fuck it was pretty insane.
And I mean I was blown away because for those of you that don't know 10 planet
Austin,
we had a grand opening.
It's,
it's at the honor and academy and a man.
I had never been there when I was fucking Florida.
That places is gigantic.
Crazy.
It's incredible.
[inaudible] doesn't do anything half assed.
No,
no.
You're puts his heart and soul and everything.
He's got a special knack for creating things and putting things together.
He's an executive producer man.
He puts him,
he's good at it and everything.
You go to dinner and it's like,
I've never had a dinner like this.
I was on a boat and there's just a hose everywhere.
I'm like,
never been on a boat like this for reals.
Never been on a boat like Ziggy smallest types.
Like,
this is how we do it.
His playlist has switched from the heavens.
I'm like,
can I have that playlist?
He's like,
sure,
he's the best.
He's just an unusual dude.
He really is very,
very unusual dude.
Yeah.
And so Alex wanted to do a piece on me cause he's got people that work for him,
that Dude Jujitsu.
And so he thought Alex found out that I was gonna be there and he decided to go
down and interviewed.
He had an info wars.
Mike,
he's that.
He's sitting next to me during the invitation or during the tournament,
which was fucking nuts.
And he's right there.
I was like,
Alex Jones,
like,
whoa.
It's pretty crazy.
That is crazy.
And you know,
him fell in love with Hugh Jitsu.
He was there for the whole place,
for the whole tournament.
Want her to stay,
stayed afterwards,
stayed for the podcast.
He was there for,
he wants to bring his daughters to Jujitsu.
That's he wants to do Jujitsu,
does 30 pounds,
you know,
uh,
bugs to be ripped.
You ever see what he used to look like?
Dude,
he was a stud.
He wants to get skinny and why don't I know this Guy Alex Jones infomercials and
for wars infomercials.
He says the most popular conspiracy theorist.
He's like the,
Oh yeah,
I definitely wouldn't know.
He runs well.
He used to be a radio DJ a long time ago.
He's,
he's still kind of doing radio but this now most of it is on the Internet but he
does a lot of it I guess on like am stations.
I still think he syndicated.
He does both,
right.
He does like the radio part and then he does cause the dirty part.
The Internet part was when Joey came on and Joey was swearing.
You remember you've seen that thing that's all on the Internet.
That's the only Internet version,
but he has a radio version too.
I just get this app and I just him anytime he's out there,
it's always been important to him and he's just been out conspiracy theory.
He's a conspiracy theorist guy,
like a heavy duty over the top,
but he's been,
I've known them.
I've been friends with them since 99 I did.
I did my,
I did a comedy DVD in Austin.
He and I put on [inaudible] we put on,
um,
George W.
Bush masks.
I was George,
I was Bush younger and he was Bush older.
He was Herbert Walker Bush.
And that was George W.
Bush is awesome.
And we,
uh,
we've ran around the fucking Capitol building,
like where the,
uh,
the State Capitol is in Austin and filmed,
it was just so retarded shit.
I became friends with them back then.
So I've,
we've known him for 16 years now.
I bet you and him just get balls deep and confused.
And we partied in Vegas one weekend.
Joe took them out to the UFC.
He flew in and man,
he does not,
you would think that he was like,
dude,
we're out partying.
Let's not talk about conspiracy theories.
Oh,
I was ready to go.
He's got so much fucking information,
man.
Right.
You know,
and that's a funny dude.
Yeah.
He's,
I love that dude.
That dude is so cool.
I fucking,
I could sit there and hang out with them for hours and just
good guy.
He's a really good guy.
He's just a fucking crazy wacko.
Everybody thought he was crazy back in the day,
but even the last time,
uh,
Joe,
was on his show,
on the phone.
You said,
man,
all of that stuff that people were,
were accusing you of being crazy about all that shit was coming to Alex.
You said that on the radio.
I like the NSA stuff.
Like he was the first one he was saying as long time ago,
the NSA was going to be monitoring everyone's phone calls.
It was going to be recording everything you do.
People thought he was nuts.
They're like,
you're out of your mind.
There's no way that's going to happen.
Also,
one of the big ones that I've found out from him was he had this,
this,
uh,
video called nine one one the road to tyranny,
I think it's called.
And a lot of it was about agent provocateur tours.
And what it's about is how they would go into a peaceful protest and they would
send these people,
whether they're cops or soldiers,
whoever the fuck they were.
They were in government issue boots and they would send them into these peaceful
protests.
They were aware masks and they would just start smashing things so they would
pretend that they were a part of the protest,
so they go in the protest,
they'd smash storefronts,
they'd smashed car windows,
create havoc.
Then the cops had move in and in the case of the World Trade Organization,
these agent provocateur guys,
these guys that got hired to go in and start smashing shit,
they all went into a house and waited and then the cops waiting outside,
they all negotiated.
Nobody rushed in and took these people and then they eventually let them all go.
Like there was some sort of behind the scenes conversation.
Yeah,
that's when they did it.
When they did it,
they stopped the entire protest.
They made it a protest free zone and they were literally,
and this is all on the news,
they were literally telling people,
you couldn't go in there with a badge on if you had a badge that said WTO on it
with a line through it.
They were telling people,
you can't have that badge on as you go on your way to work.
She said,
you're not allowed to protest.
It was a protest free zone all because of these government agents.
Now I thought like there's no way the government actually does that,
but it turns out once I read that or once I watched it and I started reading
about it,
and it's a common tactic forever.
It's technique.
It's just like there's a bunch of CIA whistleblowers,
ex CIA agents,
John Stockwell full a youtube search.
John Stockwell,
he's written books.
He says that it's just techniques.
The way they set people up,
the way they create Patsy's.
They'll bring in some crazy,
extreme radical people in the golf.
Okay,
well you want to,
you want to be in the CIA,
help us out.
And they set them up.
They got these dumb people that they always said it's called honey banking.
They want to,
if they want to comment,
honey dictate.
What they'll do is like exactly what Joe said.
They'll get like professionals to go in there,
cost some shit,
kill people.
I'm not making this up.
This is what John Stopped.
Well says that go in there and the more people they kill,
the more effective it is actually.
So what they'll do is they'll take professional,
like a dudes that go in there and take people out and then they'll put their
patsy in that boom,
blame them,
put some shit on the fucking media.
They run the media anyways and then they shoot those,
the patsies.
We got him some crazy people.
Lee Harvey Oswald.
That's the Lee Harvey Oswald Story.
Harvey Oswald was an idiot.
I mean he's definitely an idiot.
He was smart enough to Russia.
They set them up the whole time.
He was a seasoned,
set him up the whole time.
That guy was a nut.
He was.
He falls deep and conspiracy theories like,
you know what it is.
I get scared when it goes on and this shows us that he listened to us.
It's no,
you
know,
because when you,
when you mentioned Alex Jones and you'd never heard of them,
and then when we said he was a famous conspiracy,
there's you say,
that's why I don't know Mike,
but he just does stuff powerful.
I don't shit still know what I was going to say.
Eddie,
when you are on your rant is most people,
they only know him from his broadcast and they assume that he's just like crazy
guy who just is constantly looking for,
is can see conspiracies everywhere.
When you hang with him in person,
he's like a super nice guy.
Super Sweet.
He's fun.
Just doesn't shut up
Brendan.
All conspiracy theories are,
are the way shit really is.
The way shit really is.
Not every one of them.
Not everyone.
Just because,
just because not every conspiracy theory or rumor,
whatever's true.
Does that mean you just forget about the other ones?
No,
not at all.
no,
no.
It doesn't.
But something unbounced about only looking for them when,
no,
no.
I know dudes that all they care about is conspiracy.
So they're so exhausted.
Again,
conspiracy theories are theories on how shit really is run.
Some people really like to know how their life,
every,
everything that these conspiracies theories,
uh,
all of them affect our lives every day.
And so when you think about it like that and you start thinking about my life,
this life is all because he has a big effect.
A big effect on my life was stuff like nine 11,
and all of these,
these events like these,
these shootings,
these,
all these false flag events,
our lives are affected and shootings do you think are false flag events?
Oh Man.
You're talking about sandy talking about mass shootings,
school shootings.
Hey,
you know what?
The teacher got fired for percent.
Listen to question.
We already know they're all crooks.
We know how they set them.
Who's there?
Um,
the people that are really running shit.
Okay,
let's go.
Okay.
They're not crooks.
I take that back.
People that are somewhere,
yeah.
The people that have all the power generally are crux.
Not every single one.
Not every single on.
Of course we're talking in general terms.
One of the things that you'll find in government is they'll make laws that don't
make any fucking sense and that are evil and then they abide by those laws of
benefit.
There's a lot of crazy line,
actually gay.
Here's a good one.
The Supreme Court passed a ruling that allowed corporations to act as
individuals,
so they get essentially donate as much money to a campaign as they so choose.
So if a corporation wants to elect a president,
they can essentially bribe their way and get this person in the white.
It's insane.
It's nuts that they're allowed to spend any money.
How about that?
It should be the opposite.
It should be a person should be thought of as a person and individual.
We should.
We should be thought of as individual and a corporation should be thought of as
a sole entity,
a group where people get together and work.
It should never be thought of as an individual.
Like one thing that can act and its own interest,
like it's alive to stay alive.
It's going to bribe people to make sure it has the cushy.
Has Rules and regulations.
So in that sense,
yeah,
those guys are crooks.
Like that's a crook move.
You know what I started watching.
It's really fucking good walking into a house of cards.
I heard it's really good.
It's fun.
What you love it.
You would love it because it's all about the president and his,
this guy becomes president.
No,
no spoiler alerts.
Uh,
Kevin's spacing and then you find out all the inner workings and I was like,
I'm not into politics or the,
it's,
I just find it like it's like watching a fixed game of base.
It's exhausting.
It's boring to me.
It makes me angry.
It makes me angry that these are our candidates.
This is no one that's really saying something that really resonates with me.
Everyone is saying something that's inside the parameters of the system.
So they,
they do this show and Kevin Spacey plays the president and shows all the inner
workings of like how deals are made and how they negotiate and all the behind
the scenes stuff.
That sounds dope.
It's fascinating.
It's fucking good cause it's really good.
Good writing and keep carrying me.
Shit going on,
pairing that you would love it and I had to bring it up cause I knew you would
love it and I'll never forget stuff.
All sorts of crazy deep,
dark undercover shit.
You would love it.
You'd go crazy.
And you know probably a lot of it is the case.
Like who the fuck knows man?
Who the fuck knows?
Maybe they paid Nate Diaz to go off on Fox.
Maybe there's a,
maybe there's a conspiracy there.
Maybe it is.
His manager is,
what do we talk to him about?
UFC.
What is everyone talking about?
Ds.
We're not talking about those San Joe's.
We're not talking about Overeem.
It's all about new ideas.
That was where I was conflicted as a broadcaster.
I'm so conflicted because as a Nate Diaz fan and as a comedian and fell
marijuana advocate,
I was fucking howling.
Go.
Yes,
keep going,
keep going.
They're fucking screaming in my ear,
screaming in my ear,
cut him off,
take the microwave,
caught him off.
And that was,
I am not about to cut him off.
I'm not doing it.
Sorry,
I'm not pulling.
That might go away.
I'm not being the man fucking screaming in my ear.
Shut him off on my head and you're going to have to fire me if I'm not fucking
tickets.
I deal with them to let him even get home.
The mind,
everybody.
It's you'd do.
We won.
I won and he looked amazing.
I agree.
Looked amazing,
but we know it's fucking Nate Diaz.
If if I'm,
if I'm Fox,
I'm like,
all right,
you can interview.
Don't give ds the fucking room.
I figured they talked to him.
Listen,
he had a great fight.
I thought he was going to be chill.
I thought it was good to talk about Michael Johnson.
I didn't know he's going to talk about a be chill dude.
This is how bad ass Conor McGregor is.
Three fighters called them out.
Three dudes.
Three fighters.
Three.
You see his reply?
He Rolls Royce.
So good.
I love it.
That's the fight though,
is the fight.
Well,
he'd say very good fight.
If I'm dating a white,
I'm not saying what's the right thing to do.
I'm saying if I'm looking for the biggest show,
the biggest numbers.
Oh yes.
Can you imagine that world tour?
Oh my God.
Fuck.
And it's his first fight at one 55 so he can sell that.
Look at this,
line them up with their hands out on their knees with their hands out.
I want them to beg me in front of the honorable,
that's a phantom convertible son that's about $400,000 for the car.
Damn.
This guy is so fucking unusual.
He's so unusually dudes called him out.
But it's so crazy that an MMA,
it took what,
fucking years of of of of MMA popularity.
I mean Emma is 20 what is it,
22 years old now.
What does it,
when did it start at 93 three so it's 22 years,
right?
That's not 22 years.
We're both retarded.
Almost 24 okay.
So let's think about that.
In that time in life to pass,
I'd say it's really popular for like,
since like the early two thousands when navy,
not really six 2005 okay,
let's give it 10 years.
So in 10 years of real popularity,
this is the first guy that emerges like this,
this first like superstar,
besides Brock Lesnar.
Brock Lesnar is pretty much a superstar,
but it was a different thing.
He was like a superstar coming over correct from the wrestling.
So he just carried all those fans over.
They wanted to see if he could do it.
And plus you look at him,
he'd go,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Like that's the guy that you with.
When you think of cage fighting,
you would think of a guy who looks like that you got a sore tattooed on his
chest.
It's not the best story.
It's not a good one.
Ever did that.
But um,
right when he left,
you gotta see this Dick I put on Lesnar's just it's great.
Yeah,
but Connor,
there's never been a dude like that.
Just all of a sudden everyone's talking about them.
Everyone's captivated.
I agree.
And he pulls it off.
That's the craziest shit.
He goes.
He,
he bet Dana white that he would knock out Chad Mendez inside of four rounds.
He wanted to bet $3 million,
but he called the round.
He said the second round.
He said second one.
Yeah.
Well it's the same thing he did with,
with um,
although he said he's going to knock him out inside of two minutes when we laugh
at it.
Come on Dustin poray first a worldclass opponent.
He's going,
I'm gonna knock you out in the first round.
It's crazy.
And everybody's like,
what?
Me Ma crack it.
But there's some monster fights out there waiting for him.
I just think if I'm Conor Mcgregor's manager,
I'm doing what's best for his career.
Frankie's a tough fight.
I'm not saying he can't win at Frankie's a very tough fight.
And uh,
dos Anjos is the toughest fight,
but then you got Dhea is in the middle,
have 55 huge payday,
great matchup stuff for Connor.
That's the fight I take.
First of all,
how good did Nate Diaz look physically best?
We've seen them look ripped,
shredded,
full six pack,
looked in tremendous shape and didn't even come close to winning in that fight.
I mean,
now we're throwing down in that fight.
John Johnson was beat.
He got beat inside the cage.
If you listened to his corner,
they go,
don't quit.
Stick with it.
There's still room and Adam quit screaming.
Mom quit.
What Henry Hoof says that sometimes the guys,
he yelled that out too.
Um,
um,
rumble and rumble was getting beat up by DC.
He was yelling,
don't quit.
Don't quit.
That is not what you need to hear.
Maybe someone needs to talk to him.
He's a fucking fantastic kickboxing coach,
but you can't even put that out.
That was never in the coach.
My coach has vocab quick camp cut out there.
You can't put that out.
I'll probably can't help it because it's probably what he's thinking.
Well,
it's probably thinking don't quit true but a little too,
when Michael Johnson in that fight could see you starting to,
and then we'll sit and Ryan from
just eating one twos when Nate was popping them and then doing this,
do,
oh shit.
I just rang your bell.
He just standing in front of him.
He goes,
Oh shit.
And he's pointing right at his face.
You could see Michael Johnson was like,
I can't even feel frustrated happening because he shouldn't be here.
He shouldn't be stemmed from you.
So athletic and she would use an angle is using his wrestling.
He did none of it.
I think people underestimated Nadya's that's what I feel.
Horrible idea.
But that he was an underdog in that fight,
like a pretty good underdog again idiot.
I just don't think anybody who made the line went and watched him train.
If you see what a good shape he was in and how good his hands look,
Jesus Christ,
that's as good as he's ever looked.
But before he fell the rankings,
what was e five four,
it took all that time off.
Dos Anjos beat the shit out of them a year ago.
Beat the brakes off that,
that,
that one of the things that I was thinking about was how heavy he stands on that
front leg.
You know,
he stands real heavy on that front leg and they'll sign,
just just lighten that leg up.
He was lighting that leg up cause Nate fight southpaw,
right and dos Anjos fight southpaw.
So it opens him up to that back leg kick and he was just chewing up the outside
of that fucking front leg.
Conner definitely be the favorite.
If they fight.
Great fight though.
I'll talk shit talking because Karma is not going to be able to go up to Nate
Diaz and go
no,
but that might be a problem.
Yeah.
Nate Diaz might actually punch him in the mouth.
There's no way may be is it's going to allow that.
No,
for him.
He'll wait for him in front of his fucking door in the morning sun.
Like he'll find out what room he's in and he'll wait in front of the door and
punched him in the face when he goes to get breakfast.
He really different.
So brilliant with his shit talking.
What is he going to think of like for Nate Diaz specifically?
Is he going to go cause he goes real deep.
He,
he goes right to the core.
He brings,
it won't work on d as though to want to know what a work and what won't work,
but I'll tell you what.
No one has gotten eight more emotional or no one has gotten a cowboy mo more
emotional than Nate.
When cowboy starts shit talking Nate and knocked his hat,
or rather when Nate starts shit talking cowboy and knocked his hat off,
he was getting his face.
You could tell it was fucking with cowboys like his mind and he was,
he was really emotionally wrapped up in the first round,
that fight he talked about.
He's like,
I'll never let that happen again cause I got inside my head.
I fucked up and up.
But it's the fact that Nate can do that to you.
I agree.
He makes you reluctant to do it to Connor.
I will just let them not to be liked.
Watch a shark in epic.
That's why we need this fight.
The greatest show would be just Nate Diaz and Conor McGregor.
Just give them 30 minutes,
have like a mediator a little bit and just you'd have kind of just let them go.
Overeem and Ben Rothwell in between.
I'm
a realist.
Talk.
Tell Ben Rothwell and Overeem.
Look,
you got a big bonus coming to you.
I gotta Reebok money,
Reebok money.
They would finish this thought.
Let them kill each other.
Double Reebok for both of you.
How about,
but they were my age.
She just put a fucking right there.
Then
you just,
you gotta get up.
You got to somehow know that.
Make it so they can't hit each other.
You've got to say,
listen boys,
there is millions of dollars in line for security.
You can put a fence up and put them on either side of the fence and just let
them go.
No,
that would be fucking amazing.
That's not a bad idea.
Just let him talk to the marketing.
Can you imagine the market?
You have four bad ass security guards.
All blacks in between while they're talking about,
you know,
all black black uniforms.
Some Hawaiians,
big guys,
big Samoan looking will fucking snap various ones cause they don't get her to
agree.
You can't really hurt.
It's like Mark Hunt
any more than he was in his prime.
He put them on a phone like they're in a prison.
You know what I mean?
With the glass.
They just talk to each other on the fucking phone.
That's not a bad idea.
It's a prison glass shift.
That is actually a good idea.
Eddie Bravo at too strong ideas.
The prison.
You know why?
Cause you're the only one that's not high here.
We're on the same level.
I'm not feeling,
I'm feeling as ideas.
I'm screaming at the fucking phone he met to meet Blue Fox is going to go.
Yeah,
it's like a Josie is would be the host.
That'd be brilliant
ideas start off the my God hilarious dude.
But uh,
Diaz wants to speak fight cause he's getting paid 20 and 20 that is that real.
Have we have we,
we,
we sure I'm positive.
That doesn't solve the payouts at the commission.
Now he might not want to and you might have on just flows bonus.
But as far as contractually that we know it's 2020 now I'm not blaming the UFC.
I be,
I don't know what it's gotten me.
I don't,
hopefully he's not in the tough contract.
That's bad management though.
That's horrible.
Manager as big of a star as he is that motherfuckers should we get in at least
one 21 20th fight?
Yeah,
I agree.
And more than that,
probably.
He didn't fight for awhile.
Nate Diaz is a giant star.
Let me tell you this,
when he went out into that arena,
they went fucking crazy.
That crowd went fucking crazy.
When Nate Diaz is like raising his arms after every round,
they went fucking,
who are we talking about?
Think about all the stars on the car.
Who,
who's the number one most top click guy right now?
That one can do that one guy.
Well,
his performance,
first of all,
was outstanding against a guy in Michael Johnson who is an up and coming
lightweight who's been really on a tear.
Michael Johnson's look fantastic.
I thought his fight with Ben Neale Dariusz was a kind of a questionable
decision.
He probably should have won it.
Yeah,
maybe you could see it maybe that way.
I'm a dairy.
I'm a big dairy.
Who?
Shit,
he's a monk.
Neal dairy,
which is a bad motherfucker,
but I'll fight is a fight.
Right.
Great.
And why did Nate Diaz get that knee bar at the end?
He fucking had it and he had,
his time was over bro.
He all,
you need one fucking second.
No,
no,
no.
It's totally,
totally off.
It was after the buzzer.
Yeah.
He grabbed it and then the buzzer went and he extended Johnson.
He was saying,
I had your knee or something like that.
He's like,
fuck with them.
The middle was way over,
homie.
I don't know.
No,
no,
no.
Trust me,
we watched it in the truck over and over again.
It's definitely,
it was okay.
And then here's all,
I love it.
And then John,
cause I was like,
why did Johnson kick him?
And then I saw another angle is way I'm looking at him.
I'm looking at them from eye height.
Right?
So where my eyes are,
that's where their body is on the other side of the cage.
I couldn't see the knee bar and I'm like,
why would Michael Johnson kicking into the fight is over?
And then I saw the whole thing.
I go,
oh,
he deserved it because he has the 400% he's home.
Nick didn't hurt him.
I think he was just fucking with my further,
he was having a good time.
Look,
we're all talking about him,
but I wonder how much of v I wonder if you can get fined because
the FCC,
Rick,
I was asking someone on online about this today cause it's like radio,
like there's raw,
there's rules now and I think a lot of them got passed after Howard stern
because what happened with Howard stern was Howard Stern.
He got fine for questionable subject matter,
which is fucking insane.
And it's,
it was one of the weirdest moments in like free speech time because really
everybody should have stood up and said something about it.
The New York,
I mean every fucking magazine should have been talking about what a travesty it
is that you're trying to stop a show that's on the radio than anybody could turn
one way or the other.
And he's not even swearing he's playing within your rules.
But for subject matter that they were finding him like huge money,
the subject matter,
whatever you talk about,
whenever anything sexual or anything they felt felt was offensive,
they were getting him on subject matter.
Super Weird rules.
Like you can just,
you can say Dick,
but if I say I put my dick in your mouth,
you get fined.
Do you know you can say Jesus,
but if you say Jesus Christ,
you're not supposed to.
Jesus Christ.
Like there was a tennis match where one of the,
um,
one of the kit,
there was like two people playing tennis and one of them had to forfeit the
match because they said Jesus Christ,
when they missed Jesus Christ.
Exactly.
Like just saying that alone,
like I,
I saved it.
It was so a story from years ago and I always wanted to do a bit about it,
but I would get so mad when I would read it that I'm like,
this isn't even gonna be funny.
There's nothing funny about a blessing in disguise though,
because that was a big reason why he went to Syria.
Radius loves.
I just got an,
I had it for the last year.
I love it,
man.
Just resigned a five year deal.
Huge.
Such a good show.
He has the best interviews because interviews are excellent man.
Lately it seems like he's bigger than ever.
She just keeps getting,
he's getting serious.
You can't get any stars to be interviewed.
I mean he's,
it's a DFS at that point.
Is the DSD get fined for that until late kick?
Don't know.
Well he didn't kick him.
Well that's right.
Johnson kicked holding that and he didn't hurt them with that,
so that's super cool shit.
But the,
but the swearing on the air,
if you do it on purpose,
I think you can get in trouble.
I don't know what the rules are.
I'm just talking out my ass.
But I've been told click on live radio that if you,
if you chose to swear on live radio,
if they went after you,
they could find you and they can find you a lot of money.
Like hundreds of thousands of dollars.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
That's a bummer.
What's this dark man?
It's just dark that they can take money from you and it goes where?
Where do you,
where's it go?
Does it go anywhere helpful or was it just takes that and up by your red tape.
Fucking overrun system.
What?
I mean,
where's that money go?
You're just stealing money from me.
You're going to steal it and then pump it out into this machine.
Well,
it doesn't make any sense.
Even if they charge him,
I don't think he's gonna get fine.
Let's say they find them $100,000 but he gets the Conor McGregor fight.
It's worth every penny.
Right?
Oh,
it's brilliant.
Brilliant.
Yeah,
it's probably worth it.
Some reason three dudes are calling condom out,
cause that's the payday.
That's the cash or other,
his brother with the,
the pot charge,
they find them $165,000 and then they kept him out of fighting for five years.
That was the rule.
It's insane.
It's beyond silly.
Where do you see Tony Ferguson in that mix?
I could see Tony and he's right there.
That's to the Barboza Fine Tony and cowboy dude.
He be Barboza.
Holy Shit.
Dude finished up that people are scared of Edson Barboza.
No one has confident when they go into that fight,
they're like,
oh shit.
He's got,
in my opinion,
the fastest kicks I've ever seen.
Barboza man,
100% he's so fast.
He's switch kick off his front leg.
Amazing.
It's the fastest switch kick I've ever seen in my life.
I've never seen anybody faster.
He's like a like 130 pound taekwondo guy.
Like a little tiny Korean guy that moves like lightning.
That's how good he is.
I can switch.
Kick is just,
it's insane.
It's like,
well it's fast.
I could see Tony and cowboy fight.
Fuck yeah.
That's a phenomenal tongs.
Ready for those guys right there.
100% I said 2016 is Tony's.
Yeah.
I think he's a guy where everyone's like,
fuck,
I don't want to fight that dude.
He can't sleep on neuroma commando off either.
That fucking guy.
If he can get help on him cause he's not healthy.
But if he can get healthy and he could figure out a way to stop,
they get injured like he does to me.
They get,
the last one was a rib,
which you can't really control,
but the knees,
he's,
he's done his knees a couple of times now and I think he's done his knees.
Um,
after surgery.
I think he hurt his knee,
got it fixed and then heard again,
which is never good.
So people are a little bummed out if he's healthy.
Remember he slammed the champ around like Gus Antos.
Yeah,
he broke him.
He just tossed them around,
just did whatever he wanted to and once it got ahold of him,
he's a nightmare.
If he gets healthy,
they're all fun.
It's almost though like he's too tough for his joints,
you know,
it's almost like he's his,
his style so hard and he put,
he's got so much fucking strength and technique and it's so much torque.
Like when he rag dolls guys,
it's a very unique kind of rat dose of Rag Dong.
It's also Lee's rag down guys and no one rag dolls.
I agree.
Like when he ragdolled dos Anjos that was like,
whoa.
Like I ain't never seen anybody do this to dos Anjos and sane man Clegg.
We'd have beat him,
but he'd got a broken jaw and clay finished him with his jaw broken cause club
member.
A clay was doing like an arm triangle.
Yes,
and he he,
he had a broken jaw and he just says the Russian you're talking about?
No,
no,
no.
Joe Santos,
but I was in Denver think so.
We're talking about number of Madoff.
Habib number.
Good man off the way he ragdolled he beat him.
He just threw him around.
Man beat is that threw him around.
How long ago was that?
Two years.
The champ.
The same thing.
New Champion.
Yeah.
It was the last last loss on dosign [inaudible] no one wants to fight him and
you got to remember cowboy was supposed to fight them.
Who else has he fine,
but I got to say,
I don't think that dos Santos is the same dose sign.
Just we're looking at,
and I agree 100% his,
his strength and conditioning program is fucking gnarly.
He looked phenomenal.
You've got to talk to nick,
curse on,
you should have him on your podcast.
He's that speed of sport guy.
He works with Fabricio over doom,
rue salon providing a cough.
He works with a lot of Olympic athletes.
Oh,
person's tell me about him.
Yeah,
and Joe Shillings working with them now too.
He Ha he has these guys doing all these crazy plyometric drills.
Everyone swears by him.
Did I tell you I had this guy in and I talked to him and I was super impressed.
Huh?
Super impressed with his knowledge with is understanding and with his philosophy
and I was like,
what is the big difference?
Like what do you,
what do you,
what's the most important thing?
He's like foot strength.
I was like,
whoa.
He's like,
it's all about covering distance and all about the ability to move and balance
in movements and it's all about figuring out how to close the distance quicker.
And he was saying that when he fought pedis they'll sign.
Joss was just that much quicker at every exchange.
He pulled the trigger that much faster,
landed that much faster and he's like get over the course of a fight.
Even though he's only that much better over the course of the fight,
that adds up.
You get fucked up.
And that's what you saw last night though,
Sandra [inaudible] who just jumped the gun.
He was just there.
I think it's a combo things I think talking,
you know,
no knowing,
knowing cowboy,
as long as I've known him,
he,
he just,
and he even said it in his post fight interview,
he just said,
listen,
I didn't show up.
And in this business,
when you don't show up to work,
you don't feel like fighting,
get your ass whooped.
So I think he didn't feel like fighting.
He said that he's been there before too,
man.
He's been there before and he ended up Kale and dudes.
Cowboys always had a problem in the back.
The reason I didn't like this for cowboy is because of the time off cowboy.
An Act of guys who didn't have to think about it.
You give him six months,
that's trouble for cowboy.
You know,
man,
I don't know if any of that would have mattered the way dos Anjos pulled the
trigger.
I agree 100%.
I think Dos dos Anjos looked phenomenal.
But I do have to say that,
um,
there has to be some,
some sense made out of when fights gets stopped and when fights don't get
stopped.
I'm not saying that fight shit had been stopped,
but I am saying the Chris Weidman versus Luke Rockhold should have been stopped.
I agree.
I think we have to figure out how,
what is the win?
What's the win?
I mean I don't know when it is,
but I felt like cowboy was covering up and eating shots and although I'm not
unhappy with the stoppage,
like I didn't protest it.
I was like,
man,
I don't know it is for a title,
but referees there he sees what he sees.
I don't,
um,
there's a giant difference between doing that.
And then what was happening at the end of the round where Rockhold was mounted
on Weidman and just beating his brains and I agree that was bad.
Well the fact that felt to me like I was like Jesus Christ and I even,
I think I even said,
what does it take to stop fighting?
I agree because it,
he's shots.
Can he take the,
the thing is with cowboy,
why at least her Bullock talked to his coach leaser bowling and he goes,
man,
he think he was stopped early.
And I said,
I don't,
because cowboys man the game long enough.
He knows when he's in turtle like that and he's getting punched.
Cowboy knows man,
that's they're going to stop.
They go,
they give you one do something or I'm going to stop the fight.
Right.
If cowboy would just roll to guard and manage distance or grabbed him,
you know,
and control them,
the fight would have carried on.
But when I don't see cowboy responding,
I don't want to say he wanted out,
but he knows what's going on.
Trust me,
I've,
I shoot like that happen.
So when he's covering up,
you think what he really should have been doing is moving and scrambling.
He should just show.
So by just staying there and covering up,
he basically invited yes.
Stoppage.
Yes.
I'm not saying he wanted out.
He might have been hurt.
He probably was her and it's kind of like,
you know,
man,
they come in the back of there.
Listen,
if I tell you to move,
I'm close to stopping it.
Right.
And you can hear it clear as day.
Like my last fight with Travis Browne,
I turned the Rep,
I said I'm fine because I know he's going to,
I know where it's going to get stopped.
I know when I'm in trouble and they're about stop it.
I turned my go.
I'm good.
It's tough man.
Yeah.
And so cowboys has so much experience.
If you just went to guard,
you would have bought him some time.
But tell you what man,
he,
he had to be wrong because go San Joe's just teed off on it to the body that
need of the body was nasty.
And then the kick and then he on corks in cowboy said the kick didn't land.
I think he means the kicked didn't hurt him.
It definitely landed,
landed hundred percent.
But I think he meant it didn't hurt him.
I thought he said the knee is what did it.
I think the knee like really hurt him.
And then the kicker was just icing on the cake.
It wasn't,
you know,
wasn't what put them away.
But that barrage of punches to or he's fucking terrifying.
Terrifying man.
You know what's cool about him too?
We watched him get better.
Like we saw him against Jeremy Stevens.
He got Kod against Jeremy starts phone too in the UFC.
Yeah.
I mean he's a,
he's a guy who's just fucking kept on work.
He's the nicest guy in the world.
When I was in Brazil,
man,
I'm telling,
no one gave me the time of day.
This dude took me around,
introduced me to different jails.
Great Dude,
man.
I've talked to him many times backstage.
She's so calm and polite,
friendly.
He's got like,
he's at peace,
you know,
like he's like,
he's an interesting guy.
Like he's like,
he's just like,
you know,
just trying to heal my knee up,
trying to get him to,
when you root for,
if you know that you root for him to win,
I took,
not that I took heat and I say this,
whether the Brazilian or not,
I say the x factors and this is everyone and it's not dos Angeles.
I never said those Angeles was on stuff.
But to me when I was picking Dos Anjos and cowboy I said the x factor is if
someone was taking shit,
we're going to see different fighters now it can be for cowboy or dos Anjos but
that's all around the board.
I'm not saying anything new.
If steroids wasn't an issue,
a performance enhancing drugs when an issue the UFC want to implement it.
The strictest drug testing ever in the history of sports.
It's true and I want to say something um,
without implicating anyone k cause this subject gets brought up a lot.
All the people were always like you guys are talking shit and you don't know
what you're talking about.
Let me just say that everyone behind the scenes,
all the trainers,
all the coaches,
all the managers,
everyone is having this conversation.
These conversations that we're having on this podcast are not unique in that
sense.
These are not ideas that we have.
These are not theories that we have.
Look Jay,
Jeff Novitsky is sniffing up these dude's ass is and he's not playing games.
And why do you think that is?
Because the EOC was like,
you know what?
Let's just make it the strictest drug testing of all time.
Hell No.
There was a real problem then.
Well,
there's definitely a real problem or was a real problem,
but the,
the idea that it's only us that's talking about it,
it's crazy because we're the only ones talking about it as publicly as we do,
but behind the scenes is a constant conversation.
Oh,
anytime I talked to anyone that game,
it's the conversation.
When we get done here,
I'll text from coaches other five.
We can't even name names where there's sometimes people come up to us and
they'll say,
someone's going to have a hard time because he's off the shit 100% and then
they'll go in there and they'll get crushed and we'll go,
whoa,
this is nuts and dot.
The thing is with with all that,
I took so much shit for that.
You've got to realize he was the fighter at the present time.
When we're talking about this,
I'm not singling out though.
I never said all those on steroids.
I said,
there's some things to me that were suspicious.
Never.
What he's done for the sport is great.
He's one of my favorite fighters.
He's phenomenal.
Whether he's on shit or not,
it doesn't matter.
My favorite fighter of all time was probably on shit.
Vandelays like if I had to choose like one guy who had the most fun watching the
Vandelay and the pride days,
he was a Goddamn Berzerker.
Every fight you'd fucking back rabid pillows.
Me.
How many times did we watch Vandelay fight in pride?
Just screaming like Cro,
cop,
Cro,
cop.
My favorite fighter of all time.
He just got busted last week.
Yeah and he got busted.
Yeah,
he got busted too.
Why do you suppose the Japanese didn't care about steroids?
They wanted you on steroids cause you haven't performed.
Why want a free shot better?
They want the freak show too.
Well they also want you to fight like crazy.
They want you to fight like a wild man.
They don't want you to win like a,
like a really close decision.
They don't want you to do that.
They want you to go out fucking Vandelay style where shogun style are named just
style.
They want you to go out on your shield and they wanted you on steroids.
They literally wanted you on.
So we know when we have a friend that went over there to,
they offered him a fight at 185 pounds.
He's like,
I fight at one 55 now we know.
They're like,
dude,
you got some shit that's going to fix that.
Said,
how much do you weigh now?
He's like won like 71 75 goes,
you have a good frame for a oneness 85
I'm terrible.
Yeah,
that's a good boy.
It's great.
But 75 you have to do it.
It's like Bobby Lee's act.
You can be one 85 no problem.
No,
Bobby Lee do his dad.
That's what he does.
He ask God everything.
Um,
but you,
you want to talking about pds,
especially when you're talking about Overeem Endo,
Santos,
oh yeah,
man,
Overeem was on some shit.
We all know this.
So it was a hundred percent hundred percent.
So the x factor was when he got caught.
Yes,
it's,
yeah.
I'm not saying anything that's not out there.
So the x factor was how,
like what kind of room are we going to get?
I'm still a big fan of over like telling you why I'm a huge fan and you know,
people think that because you,
here's the thing,
like if there's this other sports where if you accuse the guy cheating,
everybody hates that guy.
Like you know,
people will talk about certain athletes that that got caught doing something and
then people go,
fuck that guy,
man.
He's fucking cheater.
Like I heard the dude's talking about what was the deflate gate guy?
What's his name?
Tom Brady.
But he's a fucking cheater.
He's a cheater.
Nobody gives a fuck in MMA.
They don't give a fuck.
They know.
But they want to know cause we're all suspicious.
Like why does over him look so much different?
Safety.
God say it,
but even forget it or not.
He's fucking awesome dude.
It's phenomenal.
I was so impressed with Overeem on Saturday night.
That was a tough guy.
Damn fight.
And did you see the thing was doing the Wim Hoff method.
He got in 40 degree water for 30 minutes and he's,
he's breathing.
He's over him.
Hoff Co coaching.
I'm,
yeah,
Jesus.
I didn't see the Wim Hoff is from Holland as is and they got together and he's
like teaching them these methods to optimize his body and I'll tell you what
man,
just talking to Wim Hoff makes you feel like you can go run around naked in the
snow.
I listen to that shit.
I started holding my breath.
He's a man.
He's a motherfuck.
What is that?
What techniques do you use?
I use the breathing technique before I go on stage.
Really?
Yeah.
I do it for about 10 minutes before I go on stage.
I get high as fuck.
Whoa,
crazy.
You get like oxygen high taking you taking,
did you take a gigantic breath and you only let out like half of it and then you
have flooded up again.
You take the biggest breath you can.
You only let out a little bit of it and you keep doing that.
You keep doing that for minutes.
I do for two minutes at a time and then he stopped.
I mean stage.
Yeah,
like five minutes before.
So like right before.
So easy and yet so yes,
he is.
Shit ever.
I like special,
weird and breathing is just gigantic breasts.
That's it.
Can you,
can you do the easiest shit for three minutes and still,
I don't know it.
I do it.
If I start feeling sick to avoiding a feel rundown or something like that,
I'll do it for a few minutes,
so I'll just sit down and do it for like two minutes.
You know what?
I really started doing it seriously too.
I started doing it after you and I talked about on the phone when you go like,
have you been doing that Wim Hoff method?
I go,
Nah.
And you were saying the same thing.
We're so lazy.
Nobody does it.
I said,
yeah,
you know what?
I'm going to start doing it before shows.
I just do it before shows.
Oh my God,
I love it.
I had a dude off Abbot Kinney,
big,
big dude bald.
He goes,
Bro,
listen to Rogan's podcast with,
what's the dude's name?
Wim Hof,
Wim Hoff.
He goes,
hey man,
what are you doing tomorrow morning?
I'm like,
you know,
I got shit to do,
man.
He goes,
well,
every morning at four 30 we meet on the beach and we do these breathing
techniques.
Oh yeah.
Cool.
See you there man
for 30 fuck no.
Oh,
can you scale to me for never?
Yeah,
why don't you get in the water pussy?
I think they do.
Yeah.
They do that breathing shit and they're so cold.
That water in the Pacific and the woods.
Good.
So cold.
Feels fucking good.
I don't like water.
My eyes though.
Does it salt water?
Fuck with your eyes hardcore.
No,
Yoga does.
That's interesting.
In the square care products,
do you have haircare care?
No.
Real?
No,
I don't do this.
Yeah.
You know,
when I used to fuck with me,
hard dude,
when I used to do fear factor,
I used to put your sunscreen on so I'd have sunscreen in my head and then I
would go on stage that night and the sunscreen would drip because I would sweat
on stage.
Some Korean,
you drip in your eyes and it's fucking fire.
It's awful.
That shit burns.
It's really bad for your eyes to like fuck with your vision.
It's super bad for like,
I sweat so much during yoga.
All the sweat gets in my eyes.
So for the for like the next day I'm like blink trying to get it out.
That's normal.
No,
I definitely get swept my eyes.
But sweat is just like so much better than sweat with uh,
with sunscreen.
Yeah.
That's going to burn.
Yeah,
man.
Um,
I think that uh,
that whole getting in the ocean thing like is probably something people have
been doing forever to refresh their body.
Like,
I think it's instinctive.
Like th you know how they do those ice plunges,
those people,
those younger,
were there people part of the polar bear club?
My aunt does that shit.
Polar bear club in San Francisco son.
You know how it feels when you get out of that a Cryo tank.
You feel fucking amazing,
man.
I feel amazing.
And I think now mix that with the ocean.
There's energy in the ocean and it's cold.
I love it,
man.
It's the oceans alive.
Did you see that video in San Francisco Bay right next to the dock?
A shark.
Merck's a seal.
Berkshire.
Merck's.
It just leaves this gigantic puddle,
but I'm just like a movie scene.
The shark comes out of the water with the seal and it's a big gesture.
Yeah.
Jamie.
Jamie,
play this thing.
Yeah.
It's like all these fucks.
Clam chowder.
12 foot shark.
Right?
So shoot.
It's watched it.
Watch this.
Damn.
He had a right on cue.
Yeah.
Watch this.
This is fucking a mate.
Jamie's the,
we'll get the binge.
I mean,
come on,
sign and look at all that blood.
But he gets away.
Oh yeah.
The little seals like not today,
motherfucker.
He's dead now.
He's,
you'll see eating like crazy.
Oh no,
he's in trouble.
Shark.
Probably just bit a giant chunk.
Adam sees on the top,
he's dead.
Look all the blood,
not doc.
He gets a lei.
I understand,
but look at all that block.
I mean he's not going anywhere.
He's,
he's kind of moving away a little,
but he's not going.
I appreciate the effort.
Could Lord look at that puddle?
I agree.
Look at all these fucks running over from the clam chowder.
Oh yeah man.
I would be,
I'd be like,
oh shoot that's all I want to see in life.
Fuck.
I'd love to see something like that.
So crazy that it's right there and that's what,
that's just,
it opens your eyes as to what that's really like cause we,
if we were just outside of the woods right and you would sit in your outlook,
he hits him again,
boom look at this and now he's dead.
Okay now he's dead.
He's been dead.
I think that things just wiggling.
Well he's kind of doing the damn thing.
Thing is going to get away with one fin.
I wonder what is happening.
Maybe like lets it go or like Oh my God look at this.
We're watching this folks and this is like maybe 30 feet away from people.
It looks like jaws 30 he's getting away though and,
but then he gets,
we don't,
I don't know what's happening there.
I just see some motion,
motion and harder.
Do you think he is 100% do you think he's,
there's more than one seal just doesn't seem like that thing could bleed that
much luck.
He's up here now.
You know what more there might be a bunch of seals,
Joe.
He must be just checking seals.
Oh God.
That's insane.
Never gets old.
It never gets old to that seal.
Looks so little.
Do that again Jamie.
Like watch how he's,
he's got it in his mouth when he flies out of the water.
I think there's way better footage than that.
It's just in South Africans just go yes,
but clam chowder.
Shark attack.
Yeah,
but I'm saying is like if better like here,
watch this.
Watch this one more time.
Watch this up close thing.
Boom little it is.
See how little it is.
It looks like a puppy and there's blood everywhere
like a puppy because maybe we just can't tell because of the,
no,
it's too,
it's so little.
Look how little we'll go one more time.
It's so little in his mouth.
Like watch when it comes out of the water,
it's got it in his mouth.
See that?
Look at that.
That's a little,
that thing's dead as fuck.
Look at all that blood.
Can't get enough of it.
I think that there's probably a gang of them in there and he's just swimming
around jacking him just fucking full on buffet.
Golden could just eat.
I don't think they've stopped getting hungry.
He's probably just eat.
Is there any like ultimate footage it could pop throw up like from South Africa?
Oh yeah.
There's some shit like crazy be flying out of the [inaudible] away from a
hundred people just sitting there watching.
I'm Sherman's wharf chilling and this fucking great whites next to you.
But like I was saying,
like if you looked in your backyard,
your backyard was right there and you watched some crazy like crocodile tearing
apart a zebra rec right in your backyard.
You'd be like,
what the fuck?
I'm not going out there.
Absolutely.
But people like,
let's go in the ocean,
let's go swimming around.
Hey.
You know,
and I Love My,
I love surfing.
I love surfing cause it makes the,
well I'm standing on look a lot like seals and sharks eat.
Get my flippers in arms look like flippers.
When I'm lying on a surfboard,
I wear all black.
I like to wear a wetsuit because it looks like a seal.
Like Mother Nature,
like looks out for me man,
that you think they'd make the wetsuits white or something.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
That is scary.
Fucking animals.
Nothing scarier than that.
Nothing that could,
that Jesus.
And it's really easy to get those shots.
They're just,
I mean,
they're everywhere.
And so what they're doing is they're dragging a fake.
See that?
A fake seal that they pull in water sharks like who caught up in the water?
Oh good Lord.
Oh I want to do something like that,
man.
Fuck South Africa's Oh shit.
Fuck that.
Jesus Christ.
Quickly you would,
you would die.
He died.
Is that where the show him?
He does.
He's an idiot.
Do to be good.
Way to go.
It'd be a dope way to go.
Are you kidding me?
Way to go,
Bro.
I'm going to go like this.
Mad.
You're like 85 and they take you out there in a little boat.
A little boat.
When did they first feel will realize that they jumped out of the water?
I want to say that that wasn't that long ago like like a couple of decades ago.
I think there's just rumors that sharks jumped out of the last hit shark week
like two years ago.
We're like,
holy fuck,
they can fly.
I don't think they really necessarily,
wouldn't it be crazy?
How about this?
Wouldn't it be crazy if they just started doing it recently?
Like you know how we always like to think of human evolution and we think of
human evolution as being like something that is like completely and totally
unique.
Like we got really smart.
We figured out cable and the Internet and no other animals are ever going to
figure that out.
But what they're starting to say now about chimpanzees,
and it was a theory about this,
that um,
these,
these are,
these scientists were debating whether or not chimpanzees are beginning to enter
into the stone age.
Meaning whether or not chimpanzees are starting to experiment with tools to the
point where it can be thought of as a natural trait and whether or not they're
going to start teaching each other that we know that human beings at one point
in time used to be some sort of an ancient primate.
And we evolved and we developed and we grew and we became what we are today,
right?
We know we weren't this way.
No.
Oh,
was 4 million years ago.
We became this over time.
Why would we assume that other animals are doing the same thing?
And if they are doing the same thing,
we're seeing that right now at champs.
Imagine if we're seeing that shit with sharks too.
Imagine if they go,
you know what?
It looks cool as fuck dude.
When you jack a seal and fly out of the ocean just to let those cons,
no,
look at me.
You pitch calm,
surf.
It's like,
think about like what things people do to show off.
Like those flips that those BMX bikers do.
I agree.
Couldn't do that 10 years ago or 20 years ago,
they didn't do it.
Nobody did it.
All of a sudden they do it well.
These fucking sharks are starting to jump out of the water.
What if like it was like 10 years ago,
they just didn't do it.
What if one shark did it and the other sharks were like,
oh,
sharks shark got a lot of shark pussy and the other sharks.
Like I got to start doing that too.
Talking some smoked yourself retarded.
It wouldn't be the first time.
Did you see that this year?
Conspiracy theory,
there's a visual that I just saw last week on Facebook.
He had like a Zillion gazillion views,
but there's a monkey sitting in front of a screen with all these squares and a
sequence of numbers.
One through 10 pops up in the squares and you see it all mixed up just for a
flash.
And the chimp goes,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10 I couldn't do it.
Now I don't know if it's a hoax.
I was trying to do it,
but I remember I couldn't put them in order.
But the monkeys apparently,
unless it's a hoax video,
it could be.
It says chimps have a better short term memory then humans are,
it's just me because I couldn't do it.
They figured out how to do it to get food and they teach them these sequences
over a long period of time that she's your mad to do it and then they know
they're going to get food,
but they've been doing it for awhile.
And then I give him a treat.
Dude,
you remember when that dumb bitch and a patch a Pansy,
but look at the code.
It's just one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine.
It's not like some super secret code.
Watch the beginning.
See it's one,
two,
two oh well here's what's going on though.
They block out the number.
So you can't see what the numbers are exactly first.
But look at it.
At first he does it,
you see the numbers and then they do it again and then they hide the nub.
They show it to him briefly for a moment and then they hide the numbers.
Look how fast,
look at this.
I couldn't have done that.
I wouldn't have done it.
You know that that's challenging.
It's still true.
The human.
Yeah.
And it's in different orders guys.
Two different order.
Look,
get the wash that type shit.
Watch him walking on the tight bro.
Watch this again.
This is what's bananas.
Watch and walk on this fucking telephone cord or whatever.
They're terrifying.
That planet of the ape shit.
Oh imagine they got just smart enough to be like those things and planting the,
you got to take him out before that happens.
Oh,
we'd have to take 'em out.
Uh,
remember that.
Remember that lady who had like the boyfriend chimpanzee,
she,
he was chilling in a robe and shit drinking wine.
And then one day he said Nah bitch ripped her face off her face,
her friend's face.
Cause her problems cost rocking.
That's what it is.
I think that chimp was getting some pussy.
That's what I think's happened.
100% Shanken is banging him.
What are you doing over there?
Eddie Bravo on the microphone.
Chocolate with Bacon and it here.
Well that sounds good.
Definitely not opening it on the money.
I need.
I need a pair of scissors.
You got you teeth man.
I tried to steal paper so that,
so with that lady.
I see.
I thought it was heard.
I got fucked up.
Oh Shit.
Powerful teeth bite.
Bite in and man,
I'm good.
Let's just take that wrapper off though.
So it doesn't make everybody get angry at us.
So the friend was cock blocking.
That's what it was.
The frank came on was like,
Yo,
what's up chicken?
I'm trying to get,
my dad shocked anytime he went crazy after he ripped her face off.
I wonder if she like said,
hey you get out here.
If she got threatening to him.
I wonder what,
like if there was like an exchange or if he said,
all right,
enough of this cock block and I'm just going to pull this bitch his eyes out.
She had a robe on Bro.
I forget a diaper robe in the diaper.
Do you see the pictures of him and a rope?
She like dressed him up and shit.
And then finally he's like,
I want to see this fall.
Well this pictures of her too,
she got fucked and he like rip her face and more sats or something toward face
apart completely.
And the chicks on the phone,
right?
Like she's fucking monkey just killed 200 pounds.
He was huge.
I mean he was eating lunch in her bed.
I slept in her bed.
She gave me,
she gave him Xanax and she gave him red wine.
So even if he wasn't fucking her,
which he probably was fuck hundred percent yet a giant Dick,
giant chimp,
Dick and John Chimp balls.
And it's probably horny all the time.
So maybe she just jerked him off every now and again.
You know,
maybe who knows what the fuck happened,
but that chimp was our companion like he loved that was her man,
her man.
We're like,
he's like,
it wasn't fixed matter if that happened.
He wasn't fixed while Chris in a row.
Think of a dude,
a horny dude,
and he's,
he's cutting them with this girl all the time and he's never getting any pussy.
And then a friend comes over right when he thinks he's about to get the pussy.
The friend comes over and like,
you're asleep with a monkeys.
Like you fucking con you gotta Rip Pervasive Tears are apart fucking pitch.
Oh God.
What a monster.
What a terrifying thing and intelligent,
super powerful primate that rips your face apart.
That sips wine in his fucking chilling and Xanax.
She was giving it to someone who knows what the fuck man,
how hard he fucked her after the wine.
Probably have a lower tolerance and human hammered the drunken monkey sex.
I wonder if she gave him wine in Xanax.
He's going to rip that asshole.
You know what I mean?
No wonder she's living that.
It's like,
you ain't going fucking nowhere.
You're staying here.
There he is.
Look at her face son.
Oh my God.
Like if when you guys called me was like,
Yo man,
I got this chip.
Come and see it.
No,
I'm not fucking going.
And he's terrifying.
Oh,
literally tore her face apart.
Razia Shim chilling in her room and should lead the family photo there in the
yellow blue.
I don't mean to laugh.
It's so scary.
Fuck crazy bitches this.
Well,
you know,
people were allowed to have wild animals that they shouldn't be allowed to.
They just haven't changed the laws in certain places.
There's actually a documentary called the elephant in the living room that's all
about people that own wild animals,
like dangerous wild animals.
And there's parts of the country where you could just like Ohio.
There was this guy that had a bunch of them.
He had tigers and lions and elephants and shit.
And then he opened up the gates and shot himself in the head.
He was like,
fuck this.
Open the gates,
let the animals out and then fucking iced himself.
And so the cops came and the cops had to just start shooting these animals.
They had a fine of a shoot them,
but they're all this wandering down the street.
They don't know where the fuck they're going.
They've been in these fence cages their whole life.
It's horrible.
Oh,
it's so crazy,
dude.
How about the,
uh,
the kid who his parents are?
I think it was his mom owned like a crazy,
a snake,
a pet shop,
and he committed suicide by Luna Cobra by them.
The Cobra bit him eight times the I commit suicide.
Jesus cause some largely shit,
man.
Again,
good way to go.
I don't know about all that.
I'm seeing kinks or way to go gangster.
Yeah,
it's insanely painful.
I think it was.
I can't be good.
Speaking of suicide guys,
dude,
seriously?
You guys got to watch soaked in bleach,
dude.
I've seen it with,
oh my God.
Oh,
it's the brand new Kurt Cobain documentary about Courtney love.
Courtney love doing this.
She did it.
Do these.
He got tissue dude.
She killed him.
Yes.
A hundred percent dude in this doc.
It's this,
she hired dude.
One more time,
but Internet,
it's going to explode.
Going freak out on they're mind boggling.
People.
History.
History is going to be rewritten on how,
uh,
like a Jimmy Hendrix type,
I mean rockstar.
It's been out for a while.
Then they got to change.
No,
this year it came out the year 2015.
Dude,
that's one of the stories that is so crazy that when you start telling people
you have to do the mop just to get them prepared for it.
You got to prepare.
You've got to do it.
How bad is it too?
I agree to you.
Almost like with all your dudes.
I get like more and more prepared for credit.
2015.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but,
but what,
but what they do is they have to do,
but they had her out.
They have the private investigator that Courtney hired to make her look good,
but she just went through the yellow pages and hired a motherfucker.
She hired like the detective,
all detectives.
What was,
what was going through was the guys in Kurt Cobain,
Kurt Cobain,
had her sign a prenup and has all come,
this is all real shit.
When he watches,
he was divorcing her and writing her out of the will.
He was in the process of writing out of the will and since she,
she signed a Prenup,
she wasn't going to get that much and he,
she was totally fucked up on how,
and he was trying to clean this shit up according to this documentary.
And then,
um,
if she,
if she had something,
it looks,
it appears that she had something to do with his murder based on that
documentary.
It fucking dude,
they got,
oh dude,
here we go again to the,
when he shot himself,
yes.
When he shot himself,
he didn't shoot himself.
No,
they're saying he did,
but they're saying he didn't do it because he had too much heroin in his body.
How much hair and they found in his blood system could operate a gun.
There's no heroin in his body to cause 10 overdoses on people.
It was just like,
it was crazy.
Let me ask you this.
Um,
is it possible his tolerance was so high that he could just do it when you,
when you listen to it,
when you listen to all the shit that's private and she hired a private
investigator to find this missing car.
We don't know where he's at.
He bought a shotgun and he's going to,
he's suicidal.
She was just putting it all out there.
And from day one there's private investigator started taping.
Everything goes,
this girl's full is,
she was calling like TMZ leaking all this stuff cause the,
that scalar TMZ that she's calling like the MTV TV whenever Courtney was calling
MTV saying he's suicidal,
he's got a,
she bought it.
A detective was like,
how the fuck is this getting out?
And then he traits,
traits about,
he's like this bitch is releasing it.
And then with that,
with the evidence,
the way he shot himself,
if according to how he would do it,
that they found them,
the way the shotgun shell fell is all wrong.
It should have felt the other.
Beyond that though,
all this conversation to tape conversations,
he taped everything mad him.
And,
and her lawyer,
him and her,
and this is the shit she would say,
she'd be all fucked up on heroin in her voice would say,
see,
you know,
they're,
they're supposed to be looking for Kurt,
but she knows where he's at.
She's calling the rehab 13 times a day and he won't take her calls.
She's freaking out.
She's going to get written out of the will.
She needs his ass dead.
That's the way it looks.
She says shit like this to the private investigator on tape.
She'll say,
you know,
my album's coming out and,
and um,
I started this rumor that I had an Odi.
She's saying this,
she goes to,
but what should I go with this?
Should I say it was an odi or should I say no,
it wasn't an Eau de that was twisted.
It was actually me being suicidal because I can't find Kurt.
What do you think?
And the private investigators go on.
I think that's a really,
really bad I did cause,
but it's,
it's publicity.
It's for my album is one of the best documentaries.
It's amazing.
She's a piece of,
it's all on tape.
How about,
how about their own daughter didn't invite her to her wedding.
She
got married to anybody.
It's a little bit do a little bit of a,
not mockumentary but there's some reenacted.
Yes.
That's all nasty hate though still,
but
make no mistake about it.
Still.
It's a documentary with,
with evidence.
Every forensics,
a bonding,
the actual evidence.
I just fucking hate reenactments to drive me back and it doesn't look like her.
Nobody.
I'm like,
what I love when they have those fucking TV shows like 48 hours or something
like that and they have a reenactment and then the reenactment dude doesn't look
nothing like they're like,
show up with the gun.
Pretty good job though with like the Courtney and they did it go.
They had a fake Kurt Cobain's.
No,
no,
no.
That's not in the movie.
No,
you don't understand.
It's an actual documentary with me.
It's not the whole thing like that.
Why didn't the little missing pieces,
photos of Kurt Cobain instead of Courtney wouldn't release anything to him.
Courtney tried to stop in this documentary from coming out.
She tried.
She her voice scheming and lying to this private investigator.
She knows where he's at.
She's pretending that he's missing,
she keeps saying that he's suicidal.
He bought a shotgun,
Jesus.
And then the cops like the former police chief of Seattle where all this
happened.
He's on the documentary saying this was,
they got to reopen this thing.
They want a real [inaudible].
All my friends are sober.
Jamie sober.
Jamie.
So a really good at detective.
I think he's from la or he's been in a lot of major cases and he's essentially
the head.
He's right here,
like wrote the book on how to look at it in a murder investigation and he's
saying,
look at this case again and why they don't.
It's like a little corruption.
She paid,
she was paid it all wrong.
They did it all wrong.
He said usually for them to say it was a suicide,
there's like all the stuff that goes into it.
They literally,
Shit.
Nope.
Suicide.
The even that detector was like,
what the fuck?
That quick,
no one's going to do any research.
How do you go about bribing cops?
Tiny pill son,
but can you just do that?
Like if a high profile case like that where Kurt Cobain commit suicide,
who the fuck would she talk to to hook up some sort of a bribery?
How do you do something like she was a zillionaire hold on.
It was a lot of,
dumbness does a lot of bad procedure and a lot of circumstantial dumb things
that happened.
Sort of like the Jonbenet Ramsey case where they just kept getting fucked up.
They fucked up a bunch of stuff and evidence and then finally like got to
suicide with the guy,
the head detective,
the guy that was in charge of everything,
he soon got fired or quit,
forced to quit for some other scandals and she was known for paying people off.
She was just crazy.
He got,
he got in trouble for other shit as well.
The guy in charge,
the guy who didn't want to look into anything,
there was a private investigator.
The guy who put the shit together,
he went to the lead detective.
He was a former cop describing and that scares me.
He knows he knows proper procedure.
He goes up to the guy and says,
hey,
listen,
I been,
uh,
I was hired by Courtney love.
I've been on this case for the last month.
You,
you need to talk to me.
And I got a lot of shit and the guy didn't want to talk to him.
Wow.
You wouldn't talk to it's true.
Like w the hedges taken me.
I don't want to watch that.
Oh No.
You want to walk into her somewhere?
We're going to have to kill her dude.
I think the world is going to turn on her.
I know it's going to turn on her to get her to the world is going to turn on
her.
Thank God this is a comedy podcast
is because we're just finding out about it,
but when did it come out?
I saw it on the laptop.
Now it's almost over 2015 has become in 2006 they jump.
They just made it available talking about it now.
They just made it available and I heard about it on a,
the opiod channel earlier this year.
They interviewed the director.
How long ago was this?
The summer.
See that's what I'm worried about.
But just like Netflix just now,
it just sitting there.
Well that might just be it.
Netflix is the motherfucker motherfuckers when it comes to spreading shit and
then jre and when we're talking about it right now.
That's right.
We're talking about on the GRE.
I said we send a chimp shells,
fucking jug of wine and a bottle of pills to what's up about what bottle of
Viagara Nirvana shirt.
Blue Steel.
Oh my God.
With the one with the baby and the water.
That shirt.
Fuck it,
man.
I can't believe you really think that she,
you know what's crazy to me?
I mean,
I've done my best and we've all fucked up in life,
but I've done my best to try to avoid total nightmare type relationships like
that.
That seems like not just a nightmare relationship with a nightmare.
If that is true with a completely insane person who's willing to not just fake
things for publicity,
but possibly,
you know,
they're insinuating allegedly killing them.
There's a lot of jealousy there too.
But look out a brilliant fucking musician.
He was,
oh,
it's amazing.
It just kills you.
The idea that it's some unbelievably brilliant guy gets shacked up with some
knucklehead,
drove everybody crazy about Yoko Ono and John Lennon.
Like how,
how,
how was that the way,
I don't know if that was the wedge and the Beatles.
We weren't there.
I'm just guessing.
But that's what everybody says.
Anyone could pick a hot towel and he didn't even talk about the suicide note.
Oh,
check this out.
Reach Eti.
The suicide note there was supposedly [inaudible] Jamie.
It was the first,
the first half of it.
It wasn't even about it.
It's like about his music and all this shit wasn't,
it didn't sound like a suicide note.
Then at the end she pieced it together.
Practices,
signature inner backpack.
They found her practicing or practicing.
She wrote that Shit.
Oh my God.
So a lot of it was other stuff.
And then she love you.
I love you.
He was divorcing her and riding her out of the will.
He was divorcing and that's a fact in nirvana to supposedly,
yeah.
Whoa.
So she watched son,
she washed his handwriting on the paper and wrote something.
At the bottom of a paper that he had written on it.
It doesn't even match up saying forensic scientists say it doesn't match up.
She wanted to make it seem like it was something that he really wrote,
so she was trying to blend it all in together.
Oh my God,
that is fucking some dark shit,
man.
This is possible.
So I mean there's a reason.
There's a reason.
Dave Grohl,
Dave's Dave grow man,
I'm 100% convinced she was involved in it.
Somehow.
I'm 100% and I'm not.
She says there,
he got him 100% sure.
I think this is going to be like chapter will be the Jenks.
How the Genx took down that murderer do that TV shows.
Yes.
You think so?
How crazy would it be in our lifetime if all of a sudden Courtney love winds up
getting arrested and convicted for Kurt Cobain's Martin murder and then you
start thinking about all the guys that publicly dated her.
I'm like Ed Norton at Norton,
the whole tribe,
a fucking guy was dating her after the suicide alleged to have a lot of rock
stars.
Billy Corgan,
twiggy Ramirez,
well didn't need it.
It was all over the park and have a giant falling out with her after like he
helped her write that one brilliant first album that Kurt wrote that that's,
that's a nirvana.
How's that?
Which one is Tom was in it.
A doll parts.
Oh that's under,
that was a great outcome.
And every people on the inside know that Kurt put that shit together for him.
It seems like it cause she didn't want to do,
he dies that how blows up.
It was all perfect timing.
She becomes this huge star.
Doesn't want to put out,
um,
I think it was the doesn't want to put out another album and she's banging Billy
Corgan.
This is according to Billy Corgan on Howard Stern.
He said that he had to convince her to make another album.
She was afraid of course,
cause she knew I wasn't going to live for samples.
So Billy put that album together and we're all most of it in and he convinced
her to do it and help her put it all together.
He's an,
he's a brilliant role.
Doesn't even fuck with her.
Like he don't take the,
there's an Hbo Kurt Cobain Documentary,
which is brilliantly at the way it was done was amazing.
But he will even take,
you want nothing to do with it.
This one or that one.
He wanted nothing to do scary.
It is scary shit.
Scary Shit.
Yeah.
That's scary that someone can become a murderer and just integrate right back
into pop culture.
And no one,
no one away with keeping up.
She got away with it.
But this isn't,
this isn't the first documentary I remember I'll watch one a few years back when
there was another guy that was accusing her of a,
of murdering and in that documentary it was all conspiracy theory,
uh,
status back then.
Uh,
this private investigator,
he piled a little taller,
but he didn't,
he didn't release any of the tapes.
He had all the tests.
He has hours and hours of their conversations were her just bullshitting and
design the whole time.
He catches her in so many lies.
Yeah.
This is so scary.
I'm getting nervous.
I get nervous when I talk about this.
I imagine like that someone alive that does that pull in,
fills them up with heroin and writes his love,
can't do it twice the suicide note and blows his brains out.
Whatever the fuck once.
If she really did do it once and that happened.
And what year was that happen?
What do you have?
A 94 93 but check this out in their nanny there nanny was that guy that used to
fuck her preach.
Come on,
come on.
Yes,
they married or before they were,
while they were married.
Oh my God.
Wow.
They were married.
Oh,
the darkness continues.
Our roles.
Kurt Cobain,
really great dude.
When you hear her voice conniving and she knew she's a master at handling the
press.
Oh Shit.
She's a pace with it.
But back then was coming from MTV,
like all the news and it was all coming from her directly.
She was all over that shit.
So she was putting out all this.
Everybody that knows him,
everybody that knew him really well,
said he was not suicidal her for his family.
They interview his family and friends like Kirk was 100% not suicidal like he,
he put on this whole light grunge thing.
He was not suicidal.
They said a lot of times like he,
he killed himself because he had that stomach issue that was gone.
Yeah.
He didn't have that.
That was cured.
Which stomach issue?
He had a stomach problem and he would say,
man,
test.
Sorry.
Would,
there was a statement he made that said that it made him want to kill himself,
the pain,
so that's when he started doing it.
Exactly,
exactly.
I mean,
she ran with it.
She would run with that stuff.
But you saying he was cured at that time.
It was all coming from her.
You got to watch it.
We just have the whole fucking plot.
Spoiler alert.
He dies at the end.
What?
Yes.
Yeah.
She did it though.
He's,
you ever see the photos that they released on the Internet?
That was the autopsy photos I get into.
It's almost,
it's almost like what if you found out that Jimmy Hendrix is murdered by the CIA
or something.
You know there's a Jimi Hendrix book,
Jimi Hendrix,
former bodyguard is a guy who says that Jimi Hendrix was murdered by his former
manager because he was leaving his manager and that same manager killed Jimmy
Hendrix girlfriend.
God,
Jimmy,
after Jimmy Hendrix died after Jimi Hendrix died,
his girlfriend was thrown off a roof and Soho.
Yeah,
they said she committed suicide but this guy says they threw
her off a roof cause she knows that they kill Jimmy because Jimmy was leaving
his manager.
This is one thing the manager did do.
Okay.
The manager had Jimmy kidnapped,
had Jimmy kidnapped and then rescue them.
Oh your show him to show him that Jimmy needed him CISA.
So the manager had Jimmy Hendrix fucking kidnapped this factor.
Conspiracy theory.
No,
I wasn't there obviously.
But this is according to this,
this guy and apparently the kid naps door has been said before,
but the kid next door has been said before but this a shame isn't bounce.
Brilliant,
brilliant artists was that happens though.
These,
these manager characters,
especially in the old days of show business.
I mean,
think about what we're talking about in the sixties the sixties is just 20 years
removed from the fucking 40 sure.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean think about the Ford of the forties or just 20 years removed.
We can go back and back until we get to gangs of New York.
Right.
Let the crazy fucking movie with a brilliant,
yeah,
they Louis where they killing each other with that.
We're talking about a different era of humanity.
Okay.
So easy to kill people.
Back then 1960s the people that were running show Biz,
there was a lot of gangsters in the music business,
like legitimate gangsters.
They would get involved in the career of Frank Sinatra.
Yeah.
They'll get in the,
in the career of a lot of different artists.
It was very,
very common cause they can make a lot of money and they like being big shots and
they liked saying,
hey,
I'm Jimmy Hendrix manager,
let me in the door please.
And these fucking people infiltrated like that fucking guy that was in the
producer that was in with the Beatles.
The guy who shot the chicken the mouth.
They'll guy wore the crazy wigs.
What the fuck is his name?
Wall of sound guy.
The producer.
What's up the specter?
Yes.
Phil Spector.
Here's the guy who we used to always pull guns on people.
He was,
he was a producer for the fucking Beatles.
He had a very distinctive style of recording music.
They used to call the wall of sound.
Right?
Is that my same,
the real reason they quit?
Well,
this got shot.
He shot a fucking woman in the mouth in Hollywood a few years back.
I took her back to his place,
put a gun in her mouth and pull the fucking trigger and Blueberries,
Christ man,
some Hati that he picked up at,
um,
at,
uh,
like,
was it like house of blues or something or Skybar or something like that.
But right across the street from the comedy store,
she's where he met her,
took her up to his mansion,
blew her fucking brains out.
And they,
you know,
they,
they tried him and convicted him,
but this guy was probably doing that his whole career.
Cause that was,
that was the rumor was that he would strong arm people with guns.
I think that was like super common in the music business.
I think violence and the threat of violence kept a lot of people in business.
I think what?
Like people allege that I'm shook night did.
I think that's just a rap version of it.
I think people have been doing that forever.
It's crazy,
man.
So what she's done,
what she did is it's probably been done before if she did it.
I agree.
Well you guys think she did it.
Hundred percent.
God,
that's great.
You know the John Lennon assassination conspiracy theory,
you know that the CIA had him killed.
There's,
there's,
there's a lot of shit on that.
Oh Man.
Did you see the,
the guy who did it though?
How crazy is in his [inaudible] you can get someone who's crazy to do things for
you.
Like here's a perfect example.
The FBI arrested this guy in Dallas for making a fake bomb and a,
and trying to detonate it,
but the FBI gave him that bomb.
It's the whole stories.
Hilarious.
They found some really fucking stupid dude.
They talked him into doing something you probably never would have done.
They literally sold him all the equipment to go and do this,
or they gave him all the equipment.
They gave him a cell phone to act to do it.
Not well,
it was going to blow up some building.
God dammit.
But here's the to here's,
but here's the thing.
He never was going to,
it was never his idea.
They talked him into doing it.
They scheduled the whole thing.
They got him the equipment.
Then they arrested him.
Yeah,
but he's like,
they created a crime.
Yeah,
but you don't think with John Lennon,
this homeboys crazy.
He,
you don't think he's going to see we got a prison.
You got to look into it.
Who knows?
He's got to look into it.
Well,
listen,
here's the thing.
You don't get the sang if they don't let you talk.
When was the last time you saw an interview with the guy?
He's done it though.
Has he done it since you passed the murder?
Yeah.
Well,
well,
no,
you got to look into it.
It's just,
it's also you have to realize just as crazy as the soap and bleach,
you know what I mean?
I don't look into it.
If someone would tell you about it,
you'd be like,
oh,
I don't know.
You don't think you don't think he was crazy?
He was like,
let me hear you.
Let me say this.
I don't think,
I don't have any,
I don't even have an opinion on the John Lennon thing.
I've never heard it before until Eddie brought it up.
I never,
I mean I might've peripherally hurts.
Someone said the sea.
I had no,
no details though.
None.
Zero,
Zilch.
But that said,
if they wanted to kill someone,
eat one of the best ways would be get some crazy person and infiltrate them.
Even without their knowledge.
You can provide them with a weapon,
talk them into doing it.
And there's a lot of fucking morons out there.
And the guy,
the guy who allegedly killed Robert F.
Kennedy,
he doesn't have any recollection of of it happening.
He,
what he says is everyone says that I shot him,
so I probably did.
Everyone said they saw me shoot him,
but I don't remember anything.
Well,
how about that scope?
Paula means stuff that Colombian devils,
what do they call it?
Columbia and devils.
Dust.
Devil's breath.
There's this devil's breath.
Thank you.
There's this shit that they can blow.
They literally can blow it in your note.
They blow it on you.
If you breathe it in,
you become a Zombie.
You do what they tell you to do and you have no memory of it.
Like I blow it on you.
I'll say,
Brendan Schaub helped me move my couch and then all of a sudden you're fucking
Karen a couch up the stairs.
I'm not bullshitting,
man.
It's real.
100%,
a hundred percent real.
You'll put the couch down.
Now here's what's really crazy.
That same stuff that they use is the same shit they put in drama mean and those
little patches,
when you get seasick,
they give you like a little patch and it's like a little tiny amount of this.
I think it's called scope Paul and me and think that's how you say it,
but it's the same active ingredient as those patches that they give you to keep
you from fucking getting seasick.
Jesus Christ.
Man,
devil does well.
This was stuff I didn't get my hands on.
If they have a blog,
they blow it in your face and they think that that might have been where
the legend of zombies came from and that's why zombies like it was always like a
Haitian thing.
There was,
we talk about zombies,
Haitian Columbia,
like they were,
I don't know if it's this area that had this plant,
but they think that people have been using this on people for years and it
wasn't until like really recently that they realize the effects of this stuff.
Like pharmacologists started to examine the effects of blowing this shit on peas
or a short video on a advice has a whole documentary on it and have a whole
thing on your trip,
your balls.
I think I did see it.
It's scary stuff,
but I thought,
Lord illegal,
but I didn't see,
I didn't see in a documentary.
I didn't see like a test like testing people are,
it's a good point.
He kind of,
I don't remember.
It was quite quite a while ago where I saw it.
I've watched too many documentaries.
They all go in and now I've found
there's no room.
I have no room in my hard drive.
I've got to start deleting memories of my childhood,
who I'm filling my shit up.
I'm trying to hang out with you guys.
Fill it up.
Yeah,
but the problem is like,
stuff goes in and out now.
It's like some stuff stick,
like MMA stuff seems to stick like glue and there's a few things about other
things that stick like glue,
but then there's occasional documentaries that are really interesting that just
had no room.
You know what's weird is when I was a kid,
I collect uh,
football cards and I can remember almost to a t every player.
What college you played in.
It's useless information for the reason it stuck with me.
I remember looking weird,
man.
I remember weird shit.
We all do.
There's like stuff that doesn't make any sense.
Why do I know this?
A shirt?
Why don't remember this elite,
you know,
come on man.
Let's go here.
Like the plot line of like a Tom Selleck show.
You know like Magnum Pi.
I can remember whole plotlines my grandma,
why do I need that?
It's why do I need,
wow,
the fucking dude who for the helicopter and he's helping them out and then
there's the Butler guy lets him use the Ferrari and he gets in trouble with it.
Most of my vocabulary is from Acer chill or Adam Sandler.
How fucking weird is that?
That's hilarious.
My brain was like,
Yo,
let's download this.
He might not the slice Ventura literally like what?
I'll use all of it man.
Like what?
A couple of,
yeah.
All righty.
Then when he does the thing where he's like,
he has a dream and he's like,
you bit me right here.
And he was like,
wow.
I do that all the time.
Literally all the time.
If I was you,
I'd say for sure.
Stop doing that.
I know,
I know I sent,
you want to stop doing that?
I constantly quote Hollywood shuffle,
man.
Have you ever seen that?
I have not.
It's lands and Robert Townsend,
their first movie that they put together with credit cards and shit.
Super Crazy low budget.
It's fucking hysterical.
It's called Hollywood shuffle.
You remember?
I'm going to get you Sucka.
Yeah,
that's when they started making money because of Hollywood shuffle.
That kind of,
it was an underground hit shop phones in dude.
He was,
he has,
he had a hit TV show.
He probably has $1 billion.
Yeah.
But I mean that guy,
what his TV show do you have,
what is it called?
The parenthood.
Yeah,
the WB just started up.
It
definitely didn't make it,
the WPA Pena.
He used to do like these comedy specials,
like Robert Townsend presents.
And they were like,
Damon would go on and do like 10 minutes and all these different comics go on.
But he was a famous like celebrated guy back then.
Go tired of the bullshit man.
Maybe just got tired of the spotlight.
I said fuck it.
And it happened to a lot of those guys.
They realize it's not working shit cause I didn't,
well it could cause that's a Keenan's doing a keynote now behind the scenes.
Yeah,
they probably get tired of the bullshit man.
Constant scrutiny.
Yeah,
they would go,
what?
What is the benefit of this?
Yeah,
like Dave Chappelle.
Look at him and what he's doing.
Man.
Stop doing anything.
He doesn't put anything out.
He'll specials.
He's doing standup kills it still doing spec snail.
It's still writing.
I'll never have got to go see him live to see it,
which is kind of crazy.
That's kind of cool.
The one time he showed up at the comedy store,
maybe eight years ago at them in the main room.
Man,
I never seen you so blown away.
He was never seen.
Usually you're in the pack on this guy fucking eats Dick's or something
pressing,
but it's very hard to impress you.
That does.
That's a gross Smith MS characterization of how I look at comedians like bad
one,
but very few are really good that I'll sit down there and watch.
Yes,
but like for every one that like I'm just exaggerating.
Well that's for me,
that's not an exaggeration because yeah,
there's like guys that I'll definitely go see if they're there.
Like bill burr.
I'll see him every time he's there.
It's hilarious.
It's like there's a few guys like open.
Right?
Cause that's what I,
that's what I meant.
Well course.
Well you're not going to steal one ship shall come on dude.
You when it was over we were dying.
So when it was over,
you turned around and you had this look on you.
You walked down to the comedy store and he said,
I'd never been so inspired in my all my life.
You just want her to go home and write jokes and shit.
You were really spicy.
Someone really good.
That's the first instinct,
right?
It's like,
man,
I want to hit another level now.
I want to go home and write and want to get my fucking thoughts in order.
And like when you see someone that just,
that's one of the best things about living in La and you get to see all these
like really great guys go up.
They'll get to see these people go up and you go,
God,
I really think everybody likes sort of feeds off each other in that regard.
You know like you'll,
you'll watch like,
like Louis C K did two nights at the comedy store this week.
You know,
we did like,
I think he did Sunday and Monday night and then you know like a,
they'll have a show on Tuesday or Wednesday nights a girl be there are,
you know,
some of the other great guys that are in town B.
So this is one of the places,
one of the few places maybe there's only one other one.
I think maybe New York we that could happen on a regular basis.
You'll see like top level headliners like over and over and over.
What you say it's the best time I think is the best time for comedy.
I think there's no,
there's never been more really funny comics than right now.
Like as far as like me as a fan,
like say if I never did stand up again or I've never did it at all,
just watched it.
I just looked around and I compare this era to any other era.
Even people.
I don't,
people I don't know like could take rei,
the Max and Joey out of the and all the people that I think are hilarious.
Yeah.
I still think is the best time ever.
I think I look around at all these fucking people.
There's so many.
It'll be due to Stan hope and power and Dave Attell and Louis C K and Chappelle
and you fucking,
you could keep going Ian Edwards or pull a lot of people don't even know about
he and Edwards.
He's a beast.
He's a fucking monster.
He saw,
he saw and there's a bunch of those guys,
man.
There's guys like that in Austin,
Texas.
It's guys like that in Denver.
There's guys like that in New York,
these guys like that in Boston.
This is a a really unusual time.
Super unusual time.
I think it's because of the Internet because people can watch other people do
stand up now.
Like you could see like everybody set ever.
You know,
like you could watch like a Richard Pryor thing than it the Eddie Murphy thing
and every guy you mentioned,
right?
That,
I wish I had a youtube video that was a good three hour video of just all the
guys you said.
Cause anybody that impresses you,
that's the one thing I knew.
If they impressed you,
they gotta be good.
Well they're on youtube.
Betty
video,
a mix of all those guys.
Burn presses the fucking shit out of me right now as the Stan home.
Anytime.
Every time I see Stan hope I want to go right.
You know,
he's another guy that inspires the shit out of me.
We had burr on the podcast today and I love Comedians,
man.
I watch all of their stuff.
All you guys,
and I think it was the f is the first podcast where it's the least amount of
time I've ever spent talking.
He just went,
oh yeah,
you're fucking,
he's uh,
he does out of my podcast too.
He's,
he's uh,
he'll joke around about it,
be an OCD or Adhd or whatever the fuck he is,
but it's real.
It's real.
He'll go from one subject to the next subject to the next subject before you
even get a word in.
He like just keep changing the subject,
but it's one of the reasons why is because he does his own podcast by himself.
He's one of the few guys that does a podcast.
He does it called the Monday morning podcast.
He does it on Thursday too.
And what he does is he just turns on his iPhone or his microphone and just
starts talking,
goes and just go.
You go for like an hour and a half bill burr.
So for an hour and a half,
he just aid DDS the fuck out and talks about heal to a fucking,
I can't,
I don't watch football,
so I don't pay attention.
But he'll do fucking an hour on the patriots,
you know,
and just go off about shores and he's crazy.
But whole areas,
his,
uh,
his podcast is good.
His standup is amazing.
His standup is amongst the best ever right now.
You know,
he's one of the best ever.
And I think that,
uh,
between him and like I said,
you can just keep going down the line.
Like Kevin Hart,
he's the most successful guy ever.
Most successful tour ever,
ever,
ever.
By far,
I think.
I think he's doing a thing in Philadelphia.
We did it.
I don't know if he's going to do it or it did do it.
It's going to do it.
50,000 seats and it had already sold like 40,000 seats,
like three months out and it's insane.
He's giant.
He's just giant.
Who's that black comedian that kind of went crazy for a lot of hymns.
Katt Williams.
What's he,
what's his current status?
He did a special like,
um,
I want to say a year and a half ago with spike Lee.
Spike Lee directed it and it was pretty good.
It was pretty good.
Um,
but you know,
he had,
he went through a real bad spell where he was,
he seemed like he's kind of losing it in mine.
My mom live in Bakersfield band.
Oh yeah.
He had a melt recently or no,
this is when all that shit was going down.
Maybe two years or just saw him have a meltdown.
There was no comedy going out because he was on drugs or anything.
That's why he filmed a special,
I think.
No,
no,
no.
Right here.
Ontario,
California.
Oh No,
no,
this was Bakersfield man.
He really,
he was just sweating and doing pushups on stage and running out in the audience.
No jokes.
He was just like,
ah,
this is pretty crazy.
Yeah.
So how long did this go on for?
We,
me and my wife left.
I'm like,
he's losing his mind.
This is not,
this is not even a show.
He wasn't even doing what your audience doing.
Like they weren't laughing.
So how,
like how long did he do it for?
How long did you left?
I left after a half hour.
I couldn't take it.
So for a half an hour he's just doing pushups and running.
Donny was like setting up the show and he's wondering around and he's talking
about gout and it,
he lost his mind 100% and that's when all that shit was going down.
I don't know what it should night involved.
Somehow something was going down,
I don't know.
Funny bit.
Got a funny bit and it's special.
You know,
you're fucked up when you're getting arrested and shook nights right next to
you.
He's hilarious.
He's very funny.
Very funny.
Before that happened,
he was on fire.
I couldn't wait to see him.
I'm so excited.
I love Cat Williams.
He's hilarious.
So good.
When he was on,
he was one of the best.
What about Pablo Francisco is,
he's still around.
Uh,
I saw Pablo may be four or five months ago at the comedy store.
Yeah.
Tracy Morgan's back.
Teresa than that.
He's um,
he started doing standup again,
but I don't think he's torn.
I know he did the comedy cellar.
It was like the first time since the accident he did that place accident.
Exactly.
They got hit by a guy who fell asleep while he was driving a semi Walmart.
Right.
Got Hit by a semi.
They got hit in their limo by semi.
Yeah.
And one of the guys with them died.
His boy died,
his buddy died and another guy has some pretty significant brain damage.
And one of the other ones that is like,
he can't remember anything.
He's all fucked up.
And then cat,
our cat,
Tracy got a broken leg and some serious other injuries.
He got really jacked,
like real bad.
Like he's,
I think he's still walking with a cane.
Got a huge settlement.
He has,
he has a funny commercial for beats that can't be enough coma for a year.
I come out and they got these headphones.
It's funny.
That's hilarious.
That's funny.
Oh Man.
Funny Man.
Yeah.
This is the best time man.
Best time for standing up.
Best time.
So many guys right now.
It's also,
um,
best time for women standups to best female comics or Amy Schumer's as big as it
gets right now.
You,
she's definitely as big popularity wise,
you know,
who is probably one of the funniest fucking
people alive.
Right.
Cummings.
She's hilarious.
SBL specialties.
That's right.
Cool.
I think it just came out right.
Whitney come here.
My last Whitney Cummings,
she's Hillel.
She's fucking smart and black shit.
Now she's white.
She was on the podcast like,
uh,
two weeks ago.
She's smart.
She's brilliant.
She's very cool too.
She's at the comedy store all the time.
Um,
I was going to say Sarah Silverman.
God Damn,
she's fine.
She know she's,
I mean she's always been funny,
but I saw her recent set,
but she did a set at the comedy store like maybe month and a half,
two months ago.
Sarah suffered
murdered.
She just super murdered.
She's,
and she's on right now.
You know,
comics go through like stages sometimes where they're inspired or maybe they're
doing too much other shit,
like maybe doing some acting.
She broke into the big time a little bit for awhile there.
Um,
well she's doing,
yeah,
she still does Jimmy Kimmel.
Yeah,
I should probably still does,
but um,
her standup right now,
it was on the flyer slash injures the piece too.
I haven't seen the lies of doing a set in a long time.
I've run into her,
but I haven't seen her doing a set in a long time.
She went last comic standing.
Yeah,
she has some show now.
I forget what it's on.
She has a podcast to Eliza.
I was first witnessed the,
the funniest.
She's hilarious right now.
She's aware and she works hard.
Dude,
that girl grinds,
I always see her at the store going over notes.
She's always like improving bits and it,
she doesn't like settle for the way a bit is.
She makes them better.
She twists them around.
She adds things or work ethic is cray cray.
Well we talked about is like she comes from the world of athletics.
Like she's used to working hard.
She's,
we used to working hard for things,
you know,
like,
so she treats it like almost like a competitive thing.
Most people don't know.
I mean she's a writer for two broke girls.
She developed two broker.
She's an executive producer.
It's her show.
She said she's a gangster dude.
Yes,
she's does documentaries on the side.
She contacted me about a documentary on violence,
on head trauma,
just do a documentary on the side for easy man,
like Woo fucking directs documentaries on the side.
But we,
she's really open about how nuts she is.
So she needs to constantly fill our time with productive activities because
productive things make her feel good about herself.
So she's addicted to progress.
Yeah,
pretty much.
She's really good.
She's smart as shit.
Dude.
I had to look up a couple of words.
I should drop some words on you like that,
but she's not fucking with you.
She's not like her.
Yeah.
She's not doing it just to make you like,
when people drop a word on me and I know what they're doing and I go,
oh,
I know what you're doing.
But she was,
you know,
that's a weird thing to say too,
but you kind of know when someone's doing it when they're not,
you know,
a hundred percent youtube her a commencement speech for a college.
It's brilliant.
It's crazy.
It's in spine.
It's funny though.
Is it funny?
Yes and no.
Yeah.
Okay.
I would,
I was about to say,
I wouldn't be mad at y'all as if you wanted to put up a two minute clip of this
Whitney Cummings.
No,
no,
never.
You can't do that.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
it's their shit and I don't know what they want out or don't want out and up to
now.
But there's a lot of people that have shit on Youtube.
They don't want to just happy Todd HBO specials coming up.
I think it's
out.
I think it's out right now.
I think it's called,
I'm your girlfriend.
And then he came out to December 18th.
Oh,
but I want to say it was the 18th but does that mean that might be bill burrs?
F is for family,
but then when it might be the same for families on Netflix.
It's on now on Netflix.
And you could binge watch it.
Yeah.
Netflix is just turning into a legit force.
January 23rd.
Okay.
Now we know.
All right.
Boom.
She's awesome though.
She's very,
very cool.
Plus she's like a cool chick to hang with.
Like you could talk to her like on the podcast.
It was just laughing and she's on.
And one of the best I've ever met.
Is she pretty or is that just those very pretty,
she's very pretty.
Yeah.
She's in an anomaly.
She's a fucking Unicorn,
which is not supposed to exist.
So there's her,
Jen Kirkman is really funny.
Uh,
Chelsea,
um,
handler.
No.
What's the other one?
Got What?
Chelsea Peretti.
Chelsea Peretti is really funny.
There's a lot of really fun.
You know,
it was fucking hilarious.
Thompson girl,
his wife,
Christina Palicki Dude,
she had me cowrite one night in the Olr.
Karanja she's a comedian or laying dude.
She's funny.
She's fun.
Like really good.
They just had a baby.
I know.
Interesting Little Tommy,
Tommy Thompson.
He's fucking killing it when he's great.
He just did his second Netflix special.
He did one Netflix special and it changed his whole comedy,
like his whole career.
One special.
He went from doing really well and clubs.
He was doing really well because it was podcast because of word of mouth.
Like people had heard,
you know,
he did.
You know,
you build a market,
like you'd go to Dallas,
you kill then people,
you come back and do the radio people.
I remember that guy.
He's really funny.
If you do that over a course of a few years,
you can build a market.
Like there was a couple of places that I did that,
like Houston before I ever had anything really going on.
Um,
but Tom was doing that and doing really well.
Then all of sudden he does his Netflix special.
Boom.
Now he's selling out theaters.
That was the tip.
Yeah,
well he had the product,
he had the tiny comedy and Ari,
Ari just sold out 1200 seats in Toronto.
Holy Shit.
1200 seats you should fear.
That's incredibly no.
And I was like,
dude,
what was that like?
And we were talking about it.
He's like,
it's amazing.
Like Ari was ready to throw in the towel just a few years ago with life.
Whose lives suicidal.
Yeah,
he was unhappy,
you know.
And one of the things that,
I don't know,
I think pretty sure he's talked about this on the podcast,
but um,
he was taking Propecia and Propecia.
One of the side effects for some people is depression.
I fucking told Callen it's bad.
It's a depressing is cal and taking that shit and that's when he's been kind of
fucking him.
You see this here lately?
Yeah.
Shave his head.
I agree.
He doesn't want to and wants to,
who wants to act and wants to stage it has to be on the stage.
The stage.
He doesn't wanna admit it,
but he loves it.
He's like,
I need to do it.
He loves good at it.
Keep doing it.
Make,
I'm on sitcoms and television shows and in um,
in,
in movies like those parts,
he does great.
Bachelor or not matched with the hangover.
Hang all this fucking funny.
It's really cause Chicago he'd fucking ripped my soul apart,
man.
His fucking,
he was on fire.
That's my point is that his standup is really what he's best at.
Yeah.
That's his gift.
And the more,
it's like one of those things,
it's like he likes doing it,
but it's,
it's,
it's tricky.
Like the more time you spend doing other things like acting,
like acting,
especially like 16 hour days on set,
that's a like if,
especially if you get a sitcom or something like that.
Yeah.
There's a lot of times we don't get to do stands out.
He's doing that are podcasts and motherfucker now with everything we got going
on,
just how often do you guys go wait two or three times a week and then we,
we have the digital series,
which that,
you know,
that takes me doing two or three times a week.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy,
isn't it?
Isn't it crazy that podcasting was just like a goof?
Just to a little while ago,
just started his wife beaters in Brian's garage,
just like fucking around.
Like,
this is a terrible idea.
I don't want to do this.
These things work to wife beaters,
these things work because you're fucking around like a show.
If this was produced on television,
right?
And your show was,
uh,
someone came up to you and they said,
this is our idea.
We're going to dress you up in the finest fashions and we're going to light you.
I'm going to put your makeup on and then we're going to tell you what to talk
about.
Ready?
Go.
You'd never be able to call yourself big Dick bandaids and start singing stupid
songs and Kalyn would start singing a song about something and they would cut
you off.
Cut.
You can't,
it can't sing a song about the muscles in your back,
you know,
they would say,
but since it's just you guys and you're just fucking around,
then it becomes what it is.
And then after it becomes what it is,
it gets bigger and bigger until someone comes along and says,
Hey,
um,
why don't you guys do that for us?
It's crazy.
It's insane.
It is insane.
Oh you guys.
Thank baby.
Do you guys ever got to get in trouble for anything you say?
Not Fox because our numbers have been so good.
They're kind of just like,
let them do their thing.
I don't know if they like they tried to get you guys to stop swearing.
Oh yeah.
Which is hilarious.
Yes.
We had a meeting to like,
is there any way you can say Dick less and stop swearing?
That means,
is that at all possible?
I mean kind of like,
no.
If you sensors,
we got to go somewhere else.
They can't,
they can't do your thing.
They can't stop.
Once things get big,
they can't stop it.
It starts rolling.
They can't stop it and then once and then once you stop fighting for the UFC,
nobody,
nobody can tell you what to do.
It's weird.
It's like now you can,
there's no strings.
You're like fucking Pinocchio.
Half up strings to hold me down to make me sad.
But now I'm free.
Hi Ho.
The mammy.
Oh,
nothing ever bothers me
to know.
It's weird man.
This time last year,
uh,
you know,
I was trying to decide what the fuck I'm going to deal.
You know,
it gets tricky man.
Trying to plot your life out.
It's like when things start getting going,
then it's like once you find something and starts getting gone,
Dennis just fall through with it and stay on it and stay focused.
Stay the course.
But for a lot of people,
like young guys,
like I got a nephew and talking to my nephew about like what he wants to do.
I'm like,
you got to find what you want.
Like what is it you'll want.
Yes.
But for a lot of people it's hard to find a thing and once you find a thing then
you're like,
fuck,
I'm going for it.
You know,
like once you find a thing and go for it.
But it's hard to find that thing for a lot of people.
And this is a lot of people that have a Gig.
So they have a thing that they love,
like maybe like tattooing or something like that.
But they got this job so they can only tattoo on like Saturday mornings and
their wife gives him a hard time.
And then I'm thinking about becoming to talk to is oh ah.
You know,
and they have a hard time ever finding their thing and making it a Gig.
So when you get something like what you guys have,
you found a thing and it's taken off and now you're selling out of all these
shows.
Like you guys are killing it everywhere.
Yeah.
They're selling out everywhere.
They're selling out all over the country.
They do these live fire in the kitchen.
I see.
I follow them on Instagram.
You know what?
Uh,
I like your flyer.
That was my favorite so far.
Has Your face on Collins and his face on your head?
Hideous Alex fucking freaky.
That uh,
someone Photoshop that fan.
Is it Photoshop stone?
I don't know who it was.
It might be,
I don't know.
Yeah,
cause it's really good.
It was weird.
I was like,
Bob,
you thinking like I look like a pedophile.
I looked like they sell subway sandwiches.
I look terrible.
Yeah,
things are good man.
We barely talked about fighting.
You know what's interesting?
We haven't at all great whites.
You know it's interesting man is how the UFC hasn't done their own podcast yet.
Like we talked,
I talked to them about doing it a while back.
I think there was some mention about it,
but I think the swearing thing was also an issue with them.
Like there was some concern.
Meanwhile Terena swears they're all podcasts as far anymore.
That's just there.
He doesn't anymore.
Father said,
bitch please.
He very rarely swears like he used to like you,
you know you used to have those press conferences and he would swear.
I think he probably still does a little every now and then maybe beer.
But I think he also realizes it just causes more problems than it is.
It's like the freedom that you get from speaking your mind saying whatever you
want.
It's almost like it's not worth it because it causes so many,
so many hassles.
And so many fires that you have to put in.
You want to be taken serious.
You don't see like,
uh,
you know Roger Goodell cussing about Tom Brady.
I don't think people would look at the sport if you kept doing that.
That's true.
Well,
you know what,
man,
I don't want his job.
Dana White's job is fucking brutal.
That guy works so hard and he's constantly working and shit is constantly
falling apart.
There's always constantly like a new blow out,
a new,
this,
that a new fucking fire he has to put out.
It never stops.
It never ends.
That's a,
it's a pays
well,
but like 40 million a year.
That's pretty good.
Yeah.
I don't know what it pays.
I never asked figure things out.
What'd you,
you fight?
You take that Gig?
Uh,
no you wouldn't.
You'd go right back to podcasting
podcast everywhere
though,
right there.
Well,
I think,
you know,
I mean,
I like the freedom to do what the fuck I want to do.
You wouldn't get that kind of money unless you did what he did,
which was like build it from the beginning,
but you don't get that money if you come in as a fucking executive now,
like if they got to hire some new guy,
the guys getting a good salary,
I'll make some good money.
But the Dana white effect is when the sport is like nonexistent.
He got to rich friends,
rich friends,
they put up mad cash,
they lose a fuckload.
They were 44 million in the hole before it turns around with the ultimate
fighter and then it takes off and becomes this giant support.
The rich friends were key though.
Gigantic,
not just rich friends,
but Eddie and I talked about this.
It's almost like,
it's almost like we're in a movie because we would always say the same thing.
We would always say the same thing.
What we'll used to say.
There's no way the sport isn't going to take over.
It's impossible.
Yeah,
but what did we say?
We said,
this is what the sport needs to super rich dudes that are worth billions of
dollars that don't give a fuck.
Just throw all this money at the sport and make it big.
Yup.
And that's exactly what happened.
Found them.
That's exactly what happened.
And they fucked up along the way.
They hired Carmen Electra to be their spokesperson at one point in time.
See,
I dug that.
Remember that?
Oh yeah,
I dug that.
Was Paris Hilton involved as well?
No.
What?
No,
he's coming with that date.
Yeah.
No,
they really draw the line.
So I don't even think chuck was press was,
uh,
the,
um,
the king back then.
I think chuck wasn't the champion.
I think Tito was,
I mean,
you gotta mix things out.
Remember when they had girls to impose flight interviews for awhile?
I'm sure it did.
They had a few,
that was funny.
I forget who they were.
Very nice girl.
So it's Carmen Electra with Tito and [inaudible] do,
she was a dime piece.
It was like light,
light,
heavyweight.
Vidor fuck.
Yes.
Yeah.
Wow.
Crazy.
I am not mad at that.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Um,
they tried a bunch of different things.
He just tried to get people to pay attention to it and it wasn't until the
ultimate fighter.
What's crazy is the ultimate fighter almost didn't even made,
almost didn't get made.
They had to pay for the whole thing.
It's basically like a giant infomercial.
Right.
They had to essentially pay with spike TV.
Nobody give a fuck about spike TV back time.
And then they put together this show and they're losing so much fucking money.
Yeah.
Take risks though.
And then um,
they get to the finals and Forrest Griffin is fight and Stephan Bonner and the
whole fucking world tunes and then it takes off.
It just grows.
It was like the seed that got planted.
Look at that.
Carlos Newton who pull,
forget Randy.
We get Isil.
Oh my goodness.
Pedro,
his L.
Wow.
Civ Pedro just fought his last fight.
Just retired a couple of months ago.
Get ready for a lesson in submission.
That's a fucking,
that's the whole leg.
That's the biggest moose knuckle 11 knuckle.
That's the whole thigh.
It's a moose.
Ham to CI is a design.
She was very hot.
Which is very nice too.
I did a spike TV thing with her.
We hosted this car show together.
She's super like down to earth.
She's really nice.
She married now.
I don't know,
I'm not a gossip pound.
Jamie is,
I'll ask him.
He probably knows she taken to them.
She's older.
She's probably still hot as fuck.
Oh I agree.
She did post fight interviews.
Right.
And didn't like there was a playboy playmate.
There was another one I forgot Casey case.
His daughter did carry case him.
Yeah.
You know,
you gotta try and get a swing.
You're not doing,
they were just,
they were doing a bunch of different things.
They got on best damn sports show.
Remember that?
Yes.
And uh,
Leanne Tweeten,
uh,
did a part of that as well.
It was also
super nice too.
She's super cool.
Very smart,
too smart.
She's very,
she's fucking sharp.
So she was a,
she,
but she was only involved in one because it was with best damn sports show.
Well,
what's up with,
I don't know if you can talk in a jail cause dominant.
They trying now we're this,
the first time ever had a main event.
They had Dominick Cruz in there with the three.
It was awesome.
I would like to do it with them all the time.
He's fucking great.
He's great.
And he got me fired up.
We did the smart dude.
He's great.
He's a smart dude and he's,
his knowledge of MMA is just fucking outstanding,
especially footwork and positioning and,
and,
and striking technician.
Super Technical.
And we,
uh,
did the Fox sports prelims together or the,
excuse me,
the fight pass prelims together and you look at for the joint,
where's the line?
Um,
we did the F I was one right in front of you,
dude.
Oh Shit.
We did the fs one,
no fog,
fight pass,
fight,
pass,
prelims together,
three prelims.
And he was outstanding man.
And we also did a lot of talking back stage.
He and I talked,
um,
we,
uh,
we shared philosophies.
No,
I'm good dude.
We were talking about,
um,
uh,
upcoming matchups like how we thought about this fight or that fight and what
he,
he really favored cowboy over a dos Anjos which I thought was interesting.
I think.
Yeah,
I think a lot of people did.
I thought it was,
who the fuck knows.
Fight me too.
I felt like do with the pressure that dos Anjos put on Pedis.
I felt like that's gonna fuck with anybody man.
I agree.
It can be tough to beat that guy.
Very tough.
Yup.
He's on the ground so I'm going to have to catch him when he's making that mad
charge.
And I think someone with like the kind of footwork that Connor has might have
the best chance,
but we're going to,
if those to do match up,
you're going to see pressure that Connor's never experienced before.
And he's also got hot fail Codero which,
who's a phenomenal striking coach.
One of the best in the world.
He's going to break down like what Connor's doing and Connor's movement tracking
him down.
You're right.
Cause we haven't seen enough footage to really break that down and we haven't
seen Connor would that pressure.
You know what I'm saying?
The other thing is,
is when Connor hits people that left hand,
it's game over.
Oh,
I don't think it's game over for Dos Anjos he's too big.
My Guy.
It might be,
but yeah,
that's tough.
You're talking about a different weight class now at the power.
Does he take the power totally into the lightweights and then he loses it at
welterweight?
Could he's still knock out welterweights will be knocked down versus a knocked
out Benson and Benson is fighting welter weight and he fought Brandon thatch and
fact.
She's a big fucker.
He's big and he hits hard as a welterweight and it and put away Benson.
But dos Anjos did Dosantos just fucked him up.
He was the first guy to stop Benson.
Yes.
Dosantos has like the kind of power that he takes wherever.
Like he probably won 55 is probably optimum.
He does look very thin though on the weigh ins.
He's definitely suck in some weight,
but no ivs either now.
But he looked amazing.
Amazing.
You know,
and the other thing is like people are talking about people looking different,
um,
before the,
the ped scare or before the,
uh,
the testing.
He can't say that about him.
He looks exactly the same.
He looks better than ever.
I agree.
And you also,
there's no radical change from the first time he was in the UFC.
What you see with dos Anjos is a slow,
steady progression until like the nick curse on days.
Then you see like a little,
a little stronger,
a little faster,
like,
and then you see the um,
the Pettis fight,
just phenomenal cardio.
That's the thing that blew me away the most about that fight.
The amount of cardio that he had to have to put that pace on pedes for five
rounds.
I mean that's just,
you got to be in insane conditions.
We tough to beat that guy.
Then you find out that in that fight for the two weeks before the fight,
he fucked his knee up.
He had to do airdyne sprints.
That's all he did for like the two weeks before the fight.
He couldn't do any sparring and bill put it to them since like there was nothing
wrong.
And then you saw him in this fight.
100% healthy.
He's a fucking monster.
I've talked to Ryan Parsons about him and Brian Parson said he was telling him
two years ago,
he's like,
if you keep going,
you are the champion of the world.
Like it's just a matter of time.
Ryan Gnosis Shit.
Ryan knows his shit and Ryan was telling me he was watching him and no names but
just fuck dudes up.
Dudes that are like really high level UFC caliber fighters and dos Anjos just
fucking them up in the gym.
He's,
he's,
he's a horrible matchup for anyone including college.
It's a tough matchup.
Well he's your tie with that pressure and can grapple and nasty power man's
powers,
nasty.
There's question is,
would he be able to have that same kind of approach on Connor who's very
elusive,
very light on his feet.
Like you see what we saw with the Aldo fight,
how he's,
he's moving,
he's moving back,
he's throwing side kick to the legs.
He's moving back.
Like,
would he be able to just do what he did with cowboy to uh,
to Connor?
Will you be able to do that same approach?
Like look for that straight shot.
He throws that straight left hand a lot.
The other thing to take into consideration,
this is a big thing,
is that this will be Connor fighting a southpaw,
a super dangerous southpaw.
Sure.
And one of the things about southwest,
fuck you up,
man.
They confuse the shit out of you.
Everything is coming from the wrong side.
Everything's weird that the,
the right hand is now the jab.
The Jab is the right hand.
Like why there's a lot of huge factors.
Yeah.
Ey,
it can dos Anjos deal with Connor speed.
Does Conor have the knockout power at 55 against a bigger guy?
I think he does.
I think he does because he's not going as much weight and his power.
So substantial and angles.
He surprising guys with his ankles.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a lot that goes into that fight man.
And again,
I'm not taking theme of Dos Anjos.
He's amazing champion.
I don't know if that's the marquee fight though.
As crazy as that sounds.
But here's what the thing,
it might be after Fox because you got to think that UFC on Fox,
you got millions of people to watch and we saw a destroyer and doe Sandra,
what did we talk to him about?
What's everyone talking about?
Diaz you are talking about Dhea.
So it is true.
That is true because of that post fight interview.
But I still think people were talking about those angels too a little bit cause
he just Kinda merch cowboy and they both work.
But Nate Diaz,
uh,
just,
you know,
does San Joe's has the belt,
you got daddy,
you know,
but it makes sense that you go with Nate Diaz because of all the ship talk and
all that.
And maybe that makes sense.
And,
and also,
you know,
you maybe,
some people say you can't go up in weight and get in and contend for the belt
right away.
It's a good a fight before it does.
The thing is it puts one,
a 45 in limbo.
The,
yeah.
The one of the things about the UFC though is they don't give up.
Fuck,
you don't have to follow the rule.
One of the good things about not being constrained by like a WBC and Ibf like
boxing good and bad.
Yeah.
Well they were talking about the Vladimir Klitschko fight.
Did they stripped Vladimir of not Tyson fury fury who beat Wladimir Klitschko
they stripped him of one of his titles like immediately cause he didn't want to
fight the mandatory number one contender.
So the immediately stripped him like within two weeks,
right?
Yeah.
It's like really quick and that wouldn't have it in the UFC just not going to
happen.
And in the UFC,
like there's the mandatory contender is whoever the fuck they say.
Yeah,
yeah.
If they say yes,
this is all about making money and Nate Diaz some fun and I have no complaints
about that.
I like that.
Yeah.
But if you are a fighter that would drive you crazy,
it drive you fucking now the viewer number one.
But if you are the number one contender like Frankie Edgar and you'd been beaten
dude's acids and you've been fucking up everybody and you can just knocked out
Chad Mendez in spectacular fashion and before that you beat Uriah Faber clearly
and then beat the brakes off cub Swanson and submitted fifth.
Remember light champ and before that you beat the fuck out of paint j pen.
It's normal but it's,
but it's not going to happen right now and it should happen right now.
If you're Frankie Edgar and you've been a respectful guy who just been going out
there and fighting his ass off and beating guys asses,
you're like,
that fucking guy deserves his at the title about Josie,
he gets fucked out of all this.
Yup.
My bad.
I was undefeated for 10 years,
one of the best champions of all time and I don't deserve a shot.
Nope.
You know what?
Here's the thing about that because here's the problem with that.
The only problem with that is in business,
Connor can fight right away.
Connor knocked him out with one punch.
He's fine.
Josie,
for all intents and purposes should take a long time off like you're least five
or six months.
Right.
Agree.
He has to,
I mean you,
you really should because if you don't,
you got flatlined like that and you come back quick.
We all know what happens.
You can't take a shot.
So when he's healthy he should get a shot.
But this is where it does like contractual agreements have to fall into play
when it comes to champions.
Right.
Because,
uh,
if this was any other like situation,
like I guarantee you if Floyd Mayweather and Manny Pacquiao,
if Floyd Mayweather,
they got knocked out by Manny Pacquiao,
there's gotta be some shit in the contract that says that Floyd gets an
immediate rematch and he gets it within,
I think he said he is,
I know what the contract was.
So if Manny one,
there have to be two more fights.
If Manny one,
if Floyd went,
there's no more fight in con Delta contract.
They signed.
How well you would think that all though would,
but you can't,
it's not that they don't have the power.
That's the thing goes,
here's your contract,
sign it.
There you go,
and you're going to get paid.
And I'm sure he got paid.
I'm sure he made 1 million bucks at least.
Although,
yeah.
How much do you think Conor man,
oh,
he probably made guessing.
I would guess that that's what I've been,
I've never,
I haven't asked.
I know too much that I can't talk about and I,
but I haven't asked his actual sour,
but he got paid a lot of money.
I would guarantee you.
But he wants even more than it deserves more now.
I mean,
shouldn't fight for anything less than 20 million dude.
He,
he shows a photo of his underwear on Instagram.
It gets 100,000 likes.
I mean,
he can do whatever.
He was the biggest star we were head.
If I'm Connor,
I'm in his management and I don't give a fuck what his current contract is.
I say,
I'm not doing anything till I get 20 million of flight.
He was a giant star before he knocked out all don't.
Now he's a mega star.
He's like,
he's eating sons.
He's the biggest thing we've ever wallowing up galaxies.
Three,
three ass has called them out every three in one car one night.
Yeah.
Dos Anjos um,
uh,
Nate and Charles Olivera,
he's,
he's the Floyd Mayweather of the UFC right now.
Everyone wants to fight them for the seat for the payday.
But he's way different though because he's knocking guys,
not the same fighter.
I'm saying as far as you want to fight him to make that money.
Yeah.
But even that,
like,
do you ever remember a boxing match where three winners called out Mayweather?
Like that's never happened before.
This is like everybody sees like,
they're all like your shirt,
scrooge McDuck scrooge McDuck like,
come on son.
It's true man.
Never seen anything like it.
You know,
they want all the stardom.
They want all the perks.
They want all the cash and they want and they think that they could beat him.
Look at that.
This is hilarious.
Yeah.
He says that,
uh,
people think that it was a,
it was a clean knockout,
but it's actually a fight against multiple attackers.
How he's hipping away from a big John.
These were big John [inaudible] in the face.
Now he didn't even in the face.
I seen it.
His Shin brushed over the top of all those face.
It looks like he hit him hard.
John's the best in the business.
That's crazy to look at it isn't it?
That he just knocked them dead with one shot saying wack.
It's interesting that there's this new emergence of this one guy who shit talks
and it sort of changes everyone's approach.
Boy,
did we need him though?
Oh my boy.
You did the UFC need.
Everybody needed him every,
every,
I mean,
I think the Ireland needed him to,
you know,
they needed like a hero,
like this world needed.
Um,
the,
well,
the UFC,
the UFC is a better place with Conor McGregor.
I can't say that about sliders,
but here's the thing,
okay.
When we talk about like Rhonda,
right?
Like Rhonda did a lot of shit talking to and Rhonda was over the top
personality,
but when she lost,
like there was so much hate against her,
so much backlash for her behavior.
She brought down her.
She did.
But my point is Holly emerges as this perfect opposite of that.
Perfect opposite of that.
She's super nice,
like she's really friendly and respectful and it's legit.
Like when you talked to her,
no,
there's no fakeness off camera.
She's exactly the same way.
Super confident and also like really nervous about letting anything guild who
her head like she's talking about I want to get back in the gym.
I don't want to hate her dude.
She's like,
I don't even want to talk about this.
I don't even like all this attention because I don't want to get carried away.
But isn't that like that?
Do UFC needs that too?
Like the UFC needs.
Someone comes along like Holly now and they also need someone who comes along
and shows the multifaceted approach of MMA that we all know and and see every
day in the men's divisions is now making its way to the women's division at a
very high level.
Instead of having the one person like hoist Gracie was and the early UFC is
would dominate with Jujitsu.
Right.
Nobody knew what the fuck was going on.
He would dominate.
Nobody else could keep up with them.
Technique wise,
there's a very similar situation with Rhonda.
Rhonda is dominating all these girls with armbars.
Everybody knows the arm bars are coming,
they can't stop it.
So she starts to evolve.
Her game starts knocking out people like Sarah McMahon and Alexis Davis and her
game starts to evolve and then someone comes along who has the perfect solution
for that.
And that perfect solution is very similar to what we saw in the men's divisions
when men learn how to sprawl and brawl,
and we saw worldclass kickboxers like story Smith.
Yes.
When Maury Smith into the UFC against Mark Coleman and we went,
oh look at this,
and then we see this sort of progression and now you see you in the women's
division in the women's division too.
It's like girls wanting to fight Ronda,
but they weren't.
It's not like the Connor effect where if you fight Conor,
you're making fucking bank.
The girls,
a lot of them,
they got smoked so fast,
they got maybe a couple hundred grand,
maybe not,
not even that,
and just get smoked.
It was more of the Rhonda Show,
you know what I'm saying?
It was a different animal.
Well shoes that dominant,
she was that dominant.
And I don't think you can compare at all competition wise,
what's available to a man's hundred 45 pound champion versus a women's 135
close.
That's why when people,
Ali Frazier,
no,
it's not even a car.
There's nowhere,
nothing like it.
There's some good talent in the division is shaping up.
You've got that new Russian check that just entered the multiple,
like she's a 17 time boy twirled Moy Thai champion.
She,
she,
she be sorry.
And Jay check 17,
17 different titles and org different organizations that the chick that Sarah
Kaufman I didn't notice was that earns that sound difference.
Yes.
She fought Sarah crop on an eight days,
knows crapping out crap with her.
Yeah.
And she just kept,
stayed in the gym.
Luckily she was in pretty good shape,
but to take a fight on TV,
seven days notice for the women's division,
she really good.
And her,
her striking is fucking super high level,
super high level striking.
And,
uh,
you know the,
you're going to see those is my point.
You're going to see these,
these Maury Smith types that now the enter into MMA.
You're going to see the Kira Gracie's like grace Gracie doesn't want to do it.
Like,
I don't think she has a desire to do MMA,
but you're going to see someone die.
She stopped training.
I don't think she wants a fight.
I don't know if she's a fighter.
She's been training.
She's so pretty.
She's smart.
She would just keep training.
Yeah,
I read them.
I don't start saying that.
She's not into fighting now.
Not Anymore.
I mean maybe it was just a bad,
I don't know what translation she changed your mind.
I don't know.
I know she was into it for awhile,
but I dunno end if we haven't heard anything from her,
it's probably a smart thing right on her behalf.
Just disappear and go train for a few years.
But just imagine if you get someone like a female Gary Tonin who decides like,
you know what,
I'm just going to start strangling bitches.
I'm just going to make my way into MMA.
And these girls can't fuck with my jujitsu noise.
What if you get a Serena Williams?
Exactly.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Somebody like,
let me see the arm bar.
Got It.
But dues just ripping bitches faces off.
Yeah.
If you get to that level,
that level athlete who commits to it or a Marion Jones like and they go,
wait,
I can make money over here.
Yeah,
I'm going to do this.
How about one of was track and field chicks and teach him how to kick.
Good fucking Lord know that's the big thing is about all the ticks us,
but that was one of the things about Aldo.
You know all,
they'll start off playing soccer.
It's one of the reasons why he's fucking leg kicks were so nasty.
Anchor.
Then Jujitsu and then he started picking up,
stand up.
His leg kicks were fucking ridiculous and it's because of this kind of fuck that
he gets kind of left out of it.
He's like,
he gets fucked in this.
What?
What do you do when a guy gets knocked out like that in 13 seconds in the
fairest world possible.
As soon as he's ready to go,
he gets to fight for the belt.
But you owe it to them.
You do.
But do you allow him to choose between a rematch with Mcgregor or if Frankie
Beats Mcgregor,
he fights Frankie for the belt again,
he fight no matter who has it.
Do you let a fight happen in between his fight?
Do you give him the time to recover or do you do,
do you put the belt aside,
put it on hold and say the belt does not get five for until Aldo comes back?
That's what you're doing with Rhonda.
It is what you're doing with Rhonda.
It is,
this is exact what you don't say.
You know,
not saying you I'm saying screws me.
Right.
But that is how they look at it.
They're looking at,
in terms of finances,
they think that if you look at Holly,
Holly almost lost Raquel Pennington and her pro debut or a UFC debut,
rather.
Yeah,
she won a split decision to recall in a qualified then,
uh,
she fought Marion renew is that who she fought and beat her and beat her
decisively,
then just pull out the fucking performance of a lifetime.
Again,
it's a charging opponents.
I'm gonna really played into her strengths.
If you look at the aggression that Rhonda had,
none of the other fights that she had,
no one,
no one was that aggressive chasing after people were much more respectful of her
striking ability.
But Rhonda just charged right out.
She also didn't fight Peyton price high level Rhonda district?
No,
no,
not at all.
They're all very amateur in.
If you look at like at least on paper,
like credential wise,
no one's as high levels as Holly in MMA and in the women's division other than
you want to,
you and Jay check and this,
uh,
this,
this new,
um,
Shahab Chanko it's a tough and amen.
Yeah,
it's rough.
There was a couple tough ones on that.
Um,
yes,
on that card.
But uh,
but Holly is like a 19 time.
How many times did she will at nine time world boxing champion,
this chick's 17 time world champion.
Then you've got um,
uh,
you want to know Jay check six time world Moitai champion.
I just think with Joe's out of what he's done for the sport,
give him time off,
let them feel,
and then let everything else figure itself out.
Make these huge fights and then when Josie goes,
I'm ready year from now.
You give him the title.
She,
everybody's jumping.
No,
that's what I was going to say.
Have they made the decision to run?
No.
I don't think they think everybody kind of jumped in there.
Yeah.
Then wasn't there a quote that Dana said the winter of Serone Dasani Hill gets a
call.
I think what he said was that Conard could fight for the lightweight title next.
That could be a fight.
They do.
He never guaranteed anything,
but even if he does,
they take it back.
It doesn't show was Misha was guaranteed the tie shoes.
If she beat Jessica,
I,
She Beats Jessica and they look like we're good.
Change of plans.
Yeah.
They just changed it on her.
Look,
ma'am,
but you know,
you know Diaz get say,
you know Deanna said Joe still make it happen.
I think,
I think he might've been high as fuck when he said that.
He said in their interview right after he goes,
he goes,
Joe Silva guaranteed me.
I get caught.
I'll tell you one thing,
I'm shit.
I gotta give props to Jeff Novitsky not just for what he's done.
Scare the fuck out of everybody and make them all and get off the sauce.
Cause he's definitely done that.
That's the word.
But also he was outspoken about Nick Diaz about Nick Diaz is a suspension,
not refined bullshit.
Here you've got a guy who's the fucking us Ada you,
you sought a drug guy and he's saying it's bullshit and he's saying it's a
bullshit decision.
Fuckers.
You're talking about bare bonds land.
So I'm showing big.
Marion says,
yeah.
Yeah,
he went after everybody.
That sounds good.
Weed and cycling.
Is there,
would you say,
is there a test for wheat and cycling?
I think they do.
You know there was a study recently that showed that ultra marathoners benefit
from Wade.
I think they eat it and then they eat it.
It helps them run more [inaudible].
Not all of them.
Well,
not all marathon runner smoke weed.
No,
no,
but the ones that do benefits them,
you say not all of them mean something to eat wheat and it doesn't do shit for
them.
They run off track like that.
Joshua trees I watched,
it sounded like you said all marathon runners.
No,
I said ultra,
ultra,
ultra marathon runners.
Here it is.
The debate over running wild hot for ultra marathon runners.
Marijuana has enormous benefits,
but is it ethical?
What does this in a Jamie,
what's The uh,
Wall Street Journal.
That's pretty powerful.
It's going to be some bullshit.
World's changing.
Eddie Bravo.
Since you first got me high 15 years ago,
the world has changed radically and he Bravo's the catalyst.
That's El Diablo right there.
Hello?
Right,
their first joint.
We had an ice cream Sundae.
Where's that devil dust?
That Colombian trying to get on that shit.
The crazy stoner man.
I was like,
God,
I got to get Joe.
If I could get Joe fucking stone,
they won't think I'm crazy.
I mean Shit.
Well,
there was so many misconceptions.
So many people have misconceptions to this day.
[inaudible] culture that kind of fucked,
but you know what it is,
man.
There are some people that are just fucking lazy and the idea is that pot gets
you lazy.
It's not true.
You know?
I think it does the opposite to me,
at least everybody into your reaction,
but to me it makes me paranoid of being lazy.
How about that?
So am I get high and I want to get things done.
I'm like,
oh,
I gotta clean my office.
Wow.
Some people get high and just don't move and eat Cheetos and then blame it on
that.
Really believed those people would just do the same because they're lazy you,
no matter what I really do.
I really think there's a lot of people that are just lazy.
There's also a lot of people that have just not thinking right.
They just,
they,
they just not like you don't enjoy rest unless you deserve it.
That's the reality of life.
If you just fucking off your whole life,
it's not as fun.
Like rest is fun when you deserve it.
Yes.
Like it feels good to eat after you work out.
Like if you lift and you fucking beat your ass in the gym and then you go have a
steak.
Ah,
it's the most delicious food ever.
But if you just have a stake,
yeah,
it's delicious,
but you don't even know how good it is.
Don't all good.
It is.
If you just pushed your body before you ate it,
you would enjoy it so much more.
I mean,
he might not be in the lifting or any kind of working out.
That might not be your thing.
But my point is it like if there's some things that you really need to do and
you say you fuck off and you don't do them and you get late,
you're going to hate yourself.
Yeah.
It's going to be a part of you that knows you didn't do the shit you were
supposed to do.
And if you fuck off and you get too lazy and don't accomplish things,
you're not gonna enjoy the rest as much as you do when you accomplish this.
Like you talk about it like you get home from class,
you work all day,
teach class,
you get home and you've watched.
Netflix is a joy.
I love among Muslim with breaking bad.
I always,
I always wait,
so a hundred people tell me,
dude,
you got to see it do you haven't seen it,
you gotta it's the greatest show on TV,
Bro.
I got to hear that a hundred times.
I'm like,
cool.
I want it to be true.
I just need to hear it because I can't get into it.
I watched one breaking bed,
now you gotta you gotta go back,
go back and watch the first one to write the pilot to mommy neither.
But people kept saying,
you got to give a time period of time.
Yeah,
the characters.
It's a great show.
I watched the whole first season was getting my right arm done while I was
getting my right arm tattooed.
You love watching it all on the IPAD.
That's the best.
Is it getting tattooed while you're watching a good show?
Because you don't even notice.
It was annoying thing on my arm.
I look over at Ou and then go ahead and I just started walking and just started
walking.
Dead's good.
You really liked it.
I love it.
That.
No,
no.
You haven't seen.
I've seen what good.
It shits the bed for one season though.
I'm gonna tell you this right now and I want to tell you when there's a part in
time.
I was like,
these motherfuckers,
I'm ready to leave this show.
And then they fired everybody and they hired all the new writers and they just
brought it back from the dead.
He redeemed them.
So,
and it hit a rough spot where a lot of glucose,
but they recognized that.
Of course,
that's all.
No,
no.
I haven't seen narcos.
Are you kidding?
It's going to be hard at lunch.
No,
seriously.
You have no,
I'm in the middle of this fucking president show though.
I'm in the middle of the cost of cars right now.
Okay,
I'll jump on that.
Dude.
I'm [inaudible] to episode one and a half.
Actually,
I watched it on the plane and American Airlines,
they got the little screen thing in front of you.
They had Netflix on TV's back.
We're all excited about TV.
TV sucks.
No,
it brought it in HBO and the Internet uncensored.
That's what,
that's what made it back.
Even when like you watching those shows like breaking bad,
it's cable.
They can say things you can never say on network and she can't,
can't say everything,
but they can get close like walking dead.
They get close their way.
They could get away with way more,
but they still have commercials like commercials,
fuck everything up.
You gotta you gotta watch it on Netflix or on uh,
on,
um,
apple TV.
I subscribe to those apple TV,
man.
That's the shit.
The best new show,
man.
We were all excited about show.
I'm telling good.
How's the cards?
One episode,
10 minutes into the first episode,
I was like,
oh yeah,
it's good.
I need that.
I gave up on the last man on earth,
man.
It sucks.
I got to like a season and a half and I'm like,
fuck,
I can't do it.
All right.
It started off really good.
Yeah.
You know the,
the,
the performance that the head guy,
he's fucking brilliant.
So far so good.
But he's so good at that annoying you.
You hate that character so much that it,
then you end up hating the shell cause you hate him so much.
He's like,
wow,
he's the,
the biggest douchebag.
However,
he's the last man on earth he's got from Saturday night live.
Right.
Uh,
I don't know if it Saturday night live.
What he did,
Tim and Eric stuff.
He is,
Oh shit.
You know what else is really good?
The new Bob and Dave show,
like the guys who did Mr show with Bob and Dave.
Bob and Dave.
Yeah.
Bob Odenkirk and Dave Cross.
The new one is fucking hilarious.
It's really good.
I watched one episode of that.
That's another Netflix.
I was balls deep in the wire for awhile.
She watched the wire.
I watch one episode.
I never got into it.
Why?
I know it's supposed to be awesome.
I think I went into second episode,
but it was years ago and everybody keeps saying that and that's the back burner.
I know I need to,
Jamie's nodding.
I know.
Legit as fuck.
I know I need to,
but I need to watch all these goddamn documentaries too.
Everybody's always calling.
My favorite thing.
Ductless mini documentary.
People tweet me a good documentary.
Oh you're going to get overwhelmed but well I'll just stay here for the fucking
cavalcade of chem trail documentaries.
No,
no,
I'm not into that.
I don't mean conspiracy to phone right now.
Let me ask you this.
Heavyweight.
What?
Where do you put a Alistair Overeem now?
He just knocked the fuck out.
Junior dos Santos to guy.
Not only dad,
he's the first guy to ever fight junior and not take any damage.
Who to fuck hero.
Damn.
What the fuck else has ever fought junior dos Santos and not taking any damage.
She had great footwork,
Dude.
Very smart.
They avoided each other.
But you know was that he baited them in mark.
Cause we started opening up and that second round people were booing.
But you try fight in a knockout artists with the smallest margin of error you
make,
you turn,
you dodge left instead of right.
The night's over.
So when I see that,
I'm like,
I get it.
They're just trying to get a vibe here and people are booing.
I'm like,
no,
just fucking wait for it.
Not only that,
but junior is like taking his time too and he's just,
he's bald up looking to uncork bombs.
It's respect.
Yeah.
And when Jr's throwing those punches or they're whizzing by my daughters,
they all have def on,
there's no feeling out with those.
So I respect that first round.
And then the second round,
I mean that left Hook was from weekend.
He opened them are a bunch of shit and that around,
first of all we started off selling.
He started off Orthodox.
He started killing that front leg.
He hit him with some zippers.
He's a free agent now.
He's a free agent.
Ooh,
that's big.
And then that body shot.
Oh my God.
He kept hitting him.
He was switching stances real good.
And he was constantly moving and he was saying,
he said to me after the fight,
first thing he said is that Wim Hoff breathing stuff works.
Like we were talking about it before.
I did the interview with him and he goes,
that Wim Hoff stuff works.
That's dope.
He wants to do the podcasts.
We gotta I gotta get him on the park.
He'd be worth talking about it.
Yeah.
Well that'd be great.
You want to talk about a guy who's been stopped a lot?
You know,
it's amazing.
Like he's far as far as he's gotten.
If you go back and watch kickboxing and then strike force,
or not strike force,
but he didn't get stopped.
Hey ones.
But he died.
He got stopped and pride.
I
mean,
you look at the stoppage losses that he got in k one and in prod and strike
force.
He was the champ.
He never lost in strike force.
I believe he beat for doom and Strikeforce.
He fucked up Brett Rodgers fucked up.
That was when he goes [inaudible] who's a totally different animal route.
Brett Rogers to the ground,
he kicked Brett Rogers in the beginning of the first round with a,
with a right leg kick where you see the look on Brett Rogers face.
He was just realizes,
oh shit.
It was just a completely different level of striker that he'd ever faced because
he had beaten,
um,
our Lawsky but he caught our Lawsky like nervous and tentative Arlovski you
standing in front of them and it was scared.
[inaudible] you know,
our Lasky had this period of time where he was in a rut before he went with
Jackson.
He's train with Freddie Roach.
He just was,
he was in a Rut.
He was in Chicago.
He wasn't training with Jackson and Winkeljohn down in Albuquerque.
And then they took him on and he even had a big loss when they took him on.
Um,
Keratan off Sergei carrot top tough fights,
especially at the time when he fought him.
Taniff was on father,
fuck,
he was on fire,
knocked him out.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Tano.
Karatani
I'd like to point out that that was Brennan Chavs.
Eddie Brown eyes.
Um,
I don't know.
I think he fought in glory.
Right.
Then you find the glory.
I don't know what he's doing these days.
He did some kickboxing for a while.
I think he had a back injury to that.
Set him back a bit.
I don't know what he's doing these days.
Hearing Yellowbook pages or some shit.
He's just eight.
How about fate or his opponent just gets announced like a day ago.
The worst market of all.
When did that get announced?
He's irrelevant now.
I don't give a fuck fighting that kickboxing.
The Indian kickboxing guy,
people thought it was a joke when they announced it.
I know that there's no way no one available.
There's no one available.
It's silly.
What if they made the Overeem versus fate or Phi surrogate?
Cartano I'm currently negotiating with UFC belt tour and glory.
Oh,
today thicker than a snickers.
Start getting a lot of sausages.
He looks scary as fuck.
Well,
he's dangerous.
Come on mother fucker Barnett.
Fuck them up though.
Yeah,
he did Barnett.
Fuck that.
Got Him down.
Fucked him up.
But you know what,
I remember,
man,
I remember him holding semi Schilt down and and Hammerfest in him and his
eyeball.
She and me that he said that shit shelters screaming as he's hammer fisting and
st the same bullshit and he's like mounting them.
He's like mounting them high on the chest cause semi wasn't like the best
grappler in the world.
He was just nasty kickbox great risk control giving up dudes that would mount
him and he would just hold the wrist.
He was so long and he would punch back,
strike off his back.
Pete Williams had them in the mount was he couldn't do shit to him and he
survived the round ended next round 70,
she'll throw some front kids.
We never seen that before.
Front kicks to the body to the body,
boom.
And we thought it's because he's seven foot tall.
No,
nobody,
you know with the
uh,
with normal legs can get away with shit like that.
Once I started learning crazy how that's taken off like that.
The earliest ever kicked that you learn in traditional martial arts is like one
of the most recent kicks that people are successful with.
That's crazy.
No one was throwing.
There was a video just a few years ago,
have you and I and my garage,
you're asking me about front kicks
throw.
Throw that Bruce Lee kick like that to the pool and that was my thought was
like,
man,
you got to talk to the John Anderson Silva.
God,
it was downloaded.
That data that's slow motion of vittores head snapping back from that front kick
and his legs buckling and him going down.
Anderson beaten on him.
Oh yeah,
he's AMISOM cause vetoed.
It doesn't want to fight him.
He's not going to find a veto.
I won't fight them.
And Rockhold is calling out Vituro,
which is very fascinating because what do you do there?
Here's a good question.
Do you have a rematch with Weidman or do you have him fight EOL before UL turns
50 nope,
you'll do.
Well is 63 years old.
It's got a fight.
He's going to fight for the title has to be like now like tomorrow,
no bullshit.
He's 38 like at what point in time?
I mean if he clean,
he didn't do enough for me to earn that title shot.
I think Weidman Rockhold too is the fight 100% that's the fucking fight because
if if Weidman that though that terrible spinning kick where the fuck that was.
You don't throw that we have different fight on our hands.
Yeah.
People give me a hard time about the difference between saying turning sidekick
and spinning back kick.
You're totally right.
I say spinning back kick cause that's what everybody calls it.
But the real spinning back,
it was like a donkey kick.
It's like heal up.
I always call us turning side kick,
a spinning back kick or sometimes people throw it like a spinning sidekick but
the different people also give me a hard time about the wheel kick spinning hook
kick.
Like I had a conversation with this dude about it online but that's the same
That difference,
you know Hook kick and a wheel kick is like the difference.
You don't have long left hook and a short left hook is the same kick you're
spinning using the heel.
But there's two different types of wheel kicks.
There's a wheel kick that's like with the leg is bent and then there's a stiff
leg.
We'll kick which a low Stewart and missed,
right?
No,
he landed it on hunt company kind of calf dump.
Whoa.
No,
he tried it against over him.
If you remember,
you're writing Mr.
Yes.
Yeah.
Um,
but the stiff leg we'll kick is very rare.
You have to have a sucker.
Like you have to go.
I have a guy who was like really standing in front of you,
but it's so powerful to stuff like have you seen me throw a stiff leg?
One on the bag,
but they happen when they happen.
There's deflect ones rare.
Usually it's a,
it's a bent one,
like the one with Terry,
m and M and a.
What does that symbol?
That's what I said.
He throws the wheel kick.
It's a bat lag.
Here's what happens.
It's bent up until like the point of contact and then it sort of snaps out.
And with a stiff leg one like you see me through it on a bag,
your leg becomes stiff way earlier.
It's way earlier,
your leg gets stiff like halfway.
And again,
this is like,
this is a big,
big time.
Technicalities are basically the same kick but the backache and the turning side
king,
they are different.
Like chocolate.
Dell throws the back kick,
he would throw it like he did.
He's like throwing it on bags but we're like shows people like holding the path
forward and he'll throw it.
And so he throws it like um,
donkey kick style up toes are down.
This the way Barboza throws it,
he throws it spinning sidekick or turning side kick where the foot is flat and
the heel and toes are parallel to the floor.
Nasty.
It's nasty.
To answer your question about over email,
you can make a good argument that he deserves the title shot cause he's won four
of his last fight.
He's marketable as fuck.
But Ben Rothwell knocked him out just a couple of fights ago and he's unbeaten
too.
But Ben Rothwell Flights Barnett.
Yes,
he fights Barnett and maybe the winner of that fight,
then they decide because Barnett versus Ben Rothwell is in New Jersey in
January.
Right.
[inaudible] it's a very good point.
What do you do with [inaudible] if he wins that fight?
Well,
Steve Bay went to war with Jr,
right.
Fought five hard rounds,
went to war,
lost of real close fight,
but got dropped and it legitimately lost the head of junior now,
by the way.
Oh,
I don't know about that.
That doesn't make any sense.
[inaudible] so,
uh,
it goes cane one,
right for dooms Champ Keynes won or lost keys too steep,
steep ace three.
I forget him.
For us,
that doesn't make any sense to me.
Um,
I think of junior beat him.
Junior should be ahead of him.
Even if jr just got knocked down.
Allister.
Allister is ranked behind junior.
No,
k.
That's insane.
That's insane that those ratings are fucking bananas.
Here's even worse than this.
Um,
when Conor McGregor knocked out,
although there's a Brazilian judge or writer or whatever the fuck journalists,
whoever gets to vote on these things that voted Conard down four spaces on the
pound for pound.
That was his joke.
But that makes that guy,
he is no longer credible.
You cannot have that guy vote anymore.
That's a disgrace.
It's gotta be able to fish if you go back and has over him under its current.
This is current,
even though he just knocked out Joe Santos,
he's still ranked below him and Holly Holm is resume.
She knocked Rhonda and that's automatic.
Automatic Fox is old.
How the fuck?
Oh No,
Eddie.
That's not something that I did,
man.
You don't understand.
There's,
they have like some goofy system of how they do this thing and there's a bunch
of dummies out there that somehow or another think Rhonda should be ranked above
Holly after Holly knocked her out because Ron has beaten so many people.
That's the same insanity,
the same silly hose.
Wait for us to do these podcasts and so they can talk shit about us.
Well,
this is,
this is clearly the most nutty thing ever.
If you look at the heavyweight division,
Jamie,
scroll down for the heavyweight division please.
Who Do you got on the rematch?
But hold on,
let's,
we'll go over this real quick.
Look at this.
Cain Velasquez makes sense.
Of course he was the champion.
He lost it.
Brief CEO.
He's beating everybody else.
Right.
That makes sense.
The champ are Lasky.
He's done really well.
Um,
but uh,
number two,
boy,
that's a tough sell.
There's tough sell.
When you look at the difference between the guys,
he's beaten and then you look at the guys that Allister's beaten.
If you look at Alster just beating junior,
I think you got to put him right up there with our loss.
Brown or Laskey beat Travis.
That's true.
That's a good point.
Junior beat bay.
It's fucking,
it's tough because junior like in our laps key never fought.
That's how you know it'd be a great fight.
That's the fight that's going to happen.
If Andre Loses,
if Andrea loses 100% boy who knows what's gonna happen with junior now though,
when junior get CalEd like that,
you've got to take some time off.
I have to say to me after the cane fights,
he's just took too much.
Too much.
Honestly,
I look at the fight with our laughs.
Can you,
that's a super close fight that was so close.
That was anybody's fight.
Anybody could've won that fight.
People say job one and then,
I mean most people,
I mean everyone and then our lab skis last fight against Frank Mir.
That was another like knocked out,
remarried after me.
Knocked up Travis Browne.
He knocked out big foot,
which was beautiful.
Mayor Travis Browne,
he's fighting Steve Bay.
We didn't knock out Frank Mir.
Him and Frank Mir had the one.
That's right.
Really Boring.
Really Boring fight.
Let's do it again.
Absolutely not.
So that's two fights that he had that were like really like slow to pull the
trigger and not much happens.
Travis just went after him and he went after Travis.
And I think a lot of that might've been familiarity because both those guys knew
each other really well from the gym,
from training together.
And the word was that our Lawsky would get the better of Travis and sparring
when there's nothing on the line,
it's all just skills,
right?
When you're just in the the cage,
you're training together,
there's no pressure,
there's no media,
there's no nothing.
Then you just see skills are Lawsky has some vicious fucking striking skills.
Like if you go back to just skills,
you go back to his early fights and you watch his knockouts when he was the UFC
heavyweight champion.
Fun Dude,
dude,
his right hand was up piston.
Well there was no fat to it.
He would just uncork that motherfucker on dudes and just slowly,
well black.
I think the reason a why my fight and Arlovski's was so boring,
it's we trained a lot together too.
And they were,
I mean you,
it was a,
if judges are scoring,
it was the same fight.
It was very like super close,
right?
So we knew each other.
So we were both so nervous when we fought because it's when you're going in,
you're like,
fuck,
anything can happen.
It can be tough.
Yeah.
And our Lawsky knowing that he had that advantage over Travis Browne from
training looked real confident in that fight too.
He looked real relaxed in that fight.
What a fucking crazy slug fest that was.
Ooh.
The Travis Browne and Arlovski fight might've been one of the greatest first
rounds or one rounders ever in the history of the heavyweight division.
I agree.
Especially where they're ranked.
And now you got Brown verse,
uh,
[inaudible] that's a motherfucker for a fight.
Travis Browne's fight in Montreal and Boston son on Tj
and,
uh,
your boy cruises card.
Whoa.
That's brace yourself to get advice.
A lot of people are overlooking that.
It's a great fight,
I feel like.
Made sure on was finding Sony else.
That's a great fight.
Ooh,
that's a standup war.
You know what else is a great fight that's happening in,
um,
in,
New Jersey,
Roy Nelson and no,
I'm sorry,
Josh Barnett and Big Ben Rothwell.
It's a great fight.
That's a great fight of veterans.
Ooh,
that's especially after Josh Barnett looks so good against Roy.
He looked fantastic.
It was amazing.
Five we got taken on a bunch.
What?
Nothing happened.
You know you got Roy verse,
Jared Rochelle.
Yeah,
that's a good fight too.
It's not really a blockbuster.
I'm just saying you go shots.
Got A,
you know he's got a minus p's and q's against Roy.
Yeah,
cause it's going to be in a front.
He's going to be in front of Roy.
He's been knocked up before and he's going to be in front of Roy.
You know he's not going to be Alistair Overeem and yet the way Overeem fought
Roy,
he got knocked down to remember that you're very good wrestler and he can put,
he might,
we might see Willie Nelson on his back a lot.
You're right,
you're right.
We might remind it's his game plan.
100% it's really,
he's the point man.
High level wrestling right there.
Yeah.
That fights.
Not going to break any records for our style points.
I can promise you that unless Roy just knocks him to fucking next week.
Did you see that fucking new dude and canoe?
The,
the French guy,
Bobby dog laws or DJ from street fighter.
He looks like he was bodied up so that guy is fucking big.
He got on the scale and for all I could look at it as the size of his feet.
I was like,
this guy's got canoes.
He's got canoes under his ankles.
Fucking,
he hits hard too.
But he got taken down off of a kick.
But the dude who took them down couldn't do anything with him and then he got
back up and just boxed him up.
Man.
NASC him.
That DJ is a DJ.
Louis the beast.
Him and Dj need to play some black on black crime.
The boxer?
No,
no.
You know the,
the,
the Louis who knocked out
his chest and they call out Mitroville and Mitchell.
I was like,
Huh.
And like knock them out like 30 seconds.
Derrick Lewis,
right?
Yes.
Oh my God.
Black on black crime.
Yeah.
But this dude is in no was a nasty strigoi bodied up.
He's also really good,
bad.
His striking his fucking strong.
I really enjoyed watching his striking.
I was like,
Ooh,
this guy with a few fights under his belt houses,
ground game.
Well he had good defense.
He got taken down.
You're right.
He got taken down and he got a control on the ground but not,
not much happened to him there.
And once he got up,
good lord he hit that dude with the left upper cut that just shut the lights
out.
99 he came right through the arms to right through the guard.
Like right up the middle.
There's a better upper cut over the weekend.
Not to change subjects,
but did you see your teasers Jennings and the heavyweight belt?
Yes I did.
Jennings has never been knocked down or teases.
The upper cut was fucking filthy.
Yeah,
he's nasty man.
He's a 36 year old Cuban.
No one wants to fight South Paul.
Everyone's like,
what the fuck?
And they couldn't believe Jen's took the fight cause he's over like
350 amateur fights.
Well Jennings was a,
he fought Klitschko to a decision and it had a real good fight with them.
And you know he's got to take that fight because this is a,
and this is a fight that if he beats us to it,
it tends to set some right back up.
The only thing is they're saying with rts,
like no one really knows him.
He's super dangerous.
South Paul 350 amateur fights,
just this monster and Cuba.
This the technique so clean.
He is fucking nasty.
So good.
He's older so it's time to get going.
Yeah,
well they're broken.
I feel about Yoel Romero but Yoel Romero.
Is there a guy alive built better than that man?
I mean if Mr Universe was real,
I agree.
Like if it wasn't some free could just shoots the ball into his dick hole until
his fucking neck explodes.
If it was actually like what's like the best look in body for an athlete,
it's Yoel Romero or woodly Woodley's right up.
He's right there.
You'll ever marrows weirder though.
He's weird or cause Woodley.
It almost makes sense.
It's all like,
it seems like he's fortunate.
He's like really well built,
but it all makes sense.
It looks like a super,
like first of all,
he's got all this extra neck and shoulder muscle Ninja turtle salt,
like built up like a shell,
like an end to turn in.
His waist is like that small and his,
his abs just retarded.
They don't even make sense and ask for boom.
It's like if you saw him in a comic book,
you'd be like,
why don't they make more realistic representations of men knows these
unrealistic images.
You're fucking with our body images.
You're ruining Madison.
So racist hasn't racist fuse that you got to race.
He looks just like the country.
How's that racist?
I don't think he gets the title shot though.
I fight was to boy,
they should make them fight.
He fought sick.
Apparently he had the flu.
So they were saying they're saying he was sick right up until the colts foot was
about to fall off.
And he still did it.
Hit Staff?
Yes.
Horrible staff.
Anyone by stoppage?
Yes.
So the rematch,
if you're the,
if you are,
I'm Shoba while you were either one,
whoever makes the call,
I gotta be squished in Mexico.
Okay.
If you,
if you're scrooge,
what do you think?
Weidman Rochel too.
I could see that easy,
easy.
Everything else doesn't make sense.
And it's in a big fight.
The only thing I would like to see Yoel Romero fight for the title because of
his age.
I feel so good.
He's so good and he's doesn't have much time left.
I had at that level when you're that level and also he relies on speed and
athleticism.
You're not talking about it.
Bernard Hopkins,
that's like this super crafty technician.
There's once that goes stops.
Yeah.
Bernard like he the perfect example,
the difference between Bernard and like,
like say Roy Jones Jr like Roy Jones Jr was athleticism and speed and,
and,
and all this crazy power and technique.
But he wasn't like the classically trained box or like Bernard was,
so he beat Bernard early in his career,
but then when they fought late in the career,
Bernard was older than him by several years.
Yeah,
man.
And,
and,
uh,
Bernard beat him and Bernard just outboxed him just fought with better technique
when Roy and
power was all gone and his chin wasn't the same.
Did you see him just get knocked out?
Last week he bought again.
Dude,
he got not dead.
How Nok in Russia?
Fourth Round.
Do we have a video of that?
There's like 18 people in the crowd.
Oh No,
no sir.
He's popular in Russia.
How old is he?
He fought a cruiserweight contender.
That's the problem.
How does it shit?
190500190 five he was the champion.
He's a champion at one 75 and then of course he went up to heavyweight.
He fought.
John Ruiz won the heavyweight title.
But see,
wasn't that 20 years ago?
A long time ago.
He's 46 I think.
It's not that old.
No,
he was in his path was old.
It's old.
47 46 year old Roy Jones jr knocked out in first bout as a Russian citizen.
That's so rough.
They had to throw a Russian citizen there.
Note the red,
white,
and blue theme of bloody elbow.com
has red,
white,
and blue.
It's like they,
they're like fucking,
it's like this,
that statement along with their color layout.
It's just coincidental,
but it's almost like,
fuck you.
You fucking trader.
Yeah.
It's a bummer to see him get knocked down.
They paid him.
Oh,
they knocked down.
No,
no,
they don't.
No,
you don't think that's not a legend.
They would never know.
He doesn't need money.
Well,
no.
It was a good fight up until he got,
he got tagged,
Dude.
I mean it's real.
You want to see it?
I would love to sign it and find the video behind the air.
That fucks him.
Well,
he first got dropped with an uppercut yet around.
He found a real good guy.
You fought a legit contender in the cruiserweight division and finding a cruiser
weight is like,
you know,
here it is.
The duty fought his fucking good and the guy's long and it was a good fight for
a while.
But like look at Roy's body.
Like what happened?
He's 46 fucking I know,
but look,
Bernard Hopkins is 49 and he doesn't have as wide a waste is Roy does.
That doesn't look like a man is in shape.
Wow.
He just doesn't look in good shape.
It looks like an HBO commentator trying to fight a fucking monster.
I mean,
he's still very smart,
but this is,
this is not look good to me.
Like I'm not,
he doesn't look like he's in the best shape.
Like being 49 doesn't keep him from losing body fat or 46 it doesn't help.
It doesn't help.
But how come Bernard looks so much good?
Or did I just say good or you did?
I'll take it though better,
but I wasn't in the wrong syllable.
Bernard genetically is a freak and nasty left hook to the body.
That dude just through,
meanwhile,
I don't even know that dude's name.
Kevin.
Nick died.
He gets knocked down.
I looked at the crowd like,
Nah,
I'm good man.
And homeboys like,
Nah.
Who Remembers Kevin McBride?
You remember Kevin McBride?
I don't,
he's the guy retired Mike Tyson.
Nobody remembers God.
Dang.
Yeah,
we don't want to remember him.
Well,
it's rough.
I mean,
he's Tyson quit on stool against this guy.
So Roy is still trying to same old tricks like without leaping left hook,
but he's just an here comes,
here comes the uppercut dude.
Get some in the corner here.
What'd you do?
How dare you?
Oh,
there it is.
Boom.
See now,
watch him.
When he gets the crowd,
he still has the ego.
You got to love it.
Look at him.
He's like this dude.
It's all good.
I don't think you look in the crowd.
I think he's like seeing 30 stuck his tongue.
Like it's all good baby.
Yeah,
he stuck his tongue out to the crowd.
Did he stick his tongue out or is he trying to put his mouthpiece back in?
Not sure.
Watch.
He's smiling.
Oh yeah,
you're right.
He stuck his tongue out.
But he might've been like moving his jaw too.
It might've been like this line.
He's talking in the RAF.
He said I'm fine.
He was looking butterflies.
But look at this.
Yeah,
this dude [inaudible] it's behind the ear.
That fucks on.
Yeah.
Being,
being,
being.
Look how he mixes his combinations to upper cut and here's the right hand behind
him.
Think.
Ah.
It's so hard to watch.
My bomber man is hard to watch him get filled like that.
It's like watching get beat up and then the guy does the cross thing to make
sure he doesn't die.
Huh.
And he's like groaning and moving around while he's on his back.
Super fucked up.
I don't like looking at his legs like look at his legs.
Those are like soft,
mushy legs.
You know what I'm saying?
Like when I think of a guy like Roy Jones jr I think of like [inaudible] sinewy
fast twitch,
muscle fiber.
I think of a guy in shape.
I'm looking at his legs and I'm like,
that's a guy not in shape.
Like isn't the best boxer all thug.
Look at the definition.
Like it's all missing like look at his body,
but a lot of boxes.
I like George Foreman,
George Foreman,
he flat.
Muhammad Ali was fucking jacked,
right?
Play,
got super fat.
The difference is George Foreman was a heavyweight and heavyweight who gets fat
is not giving up any weight.
You know?
I mean George still using muscle 300 pounds.
Yeah,
but he was enormous.
Even when he was fat.
Enormous muscles.
Big Boy.
When I'm looking at here,
it's like a guy who looks like he's out of shape.
He just doesn't look at all like he's in shape.
He looks like he's an analyst for HPL that jumped in there with a killer.
It's just exactly what's going on.
You know what it is.
I'll get this fucking uppercut.
Look at this.
Look in this guy's face too.
He's looking at murder.
I look at it as,
oh my God,
that right hand and put them away is terrifying.
Show that one more time.
God Damn the way that looks at slow motion.
Look at this.
Look at him.
Just a killer.
Look at her eyes and he just uncorked the perfect right hand.
The side of the Royce had watches him drop.
It's same story that plays itself out time and time and time again.
That's fighters though,
right?
They go out on the shield,
man.
Most guys,
I mean do they become,
they'll become fighters because they don't enjoy this,
you know,
but it's just so weird to watch.
It's so weird to watch it happen.
A Roy for whatever reason here,
do me a favor and put on Roy Jones Jr versus Virgil Hill.
Let's go back to the prime.
Go back to when he was the light heavyweight champion and he iced Virgil Hill
with his right hand.
I like real,
yeah,
go the highest highlight.
Yeah,
go to Roy Jones.
Highlight reel.
That's even better.
That's how this song,
dude,
the this,
I mean,
who the fuck was like this guy the best of all time?
To me,
I love him.
He's my favorite.
My favorite to watch for sure right up there.
You know,
the only other guy that,
uh,
was one of my favorites to watch,
but for a different reason.
Well,
Roberto Duran for sure,
but also look at the speed,
but I'm looking at his body son.
Look at him dancing robot.
He was amazing,
but he also had a weird body work.
He had like giant bicep muscles like his biceps were giant.
Look,
Jesus Christ,
look at that left hook.
He was just so fast,
but he relied on this.
Look at that.
Come on son.
Fast and powerful.
But once that goes away,
it's not a fucking me,
but look at the bike.
Look at his body.
Look at his body here and compare it to the body of the dude that we just
watched get knocked out.
I mean this is a fucking,
yeah,
he was 46 bro.
I know,
I understand.
No,
I mean I'm not saying that you know,
he has some sort of a work in the past.
I'm not saying it was a work ethic prom or anything like that.
I'm just saying it's just so fucked up to see no way he could train the same no
mini pads.
The ends that they had around where Vinny didn't land that one punch.
It was the only time ever in copy box history that the opponent didn't land a
punch.
It all dude.
He was insane.
He would punch you and just be nowhere near you and you wanted to punch her
back.
It was just on another level speed and and like reflex wise,
completely different level than anybody ever is that white boy doing.
It's just so sad to see this guy become the guy that we just watched because I
mean he was out.
That's what happens,
right?
If you keep fighting.
This happens to everyone yas,
man,
I just don't happen to,
I don't understand why,
especially when you're a famous as him,
he can fight whenever you want.
This is like when nobody knew who he was.
Dude,
he was insane.
He was so,
I was there for that fight.
I was there live for this really is that I forgot to do.
His name was like this light skinned black dude.
I saw that dude fight somewhere else too.
I saw that guy fight live in Mount Vernon,
New York or Malvern or White Hill,
white plains,
rather one of these local boxing events.
I saw him fight and I was like,
wow,
this guy's good.
And then I remember years later,
remember if I knew horn role Dan.
Oh yeah,
man fought them.
He fought one role.
Dan.
Wow.
I can't remember that.
I thought,
I know I didn't hack or fight him.
God.
One role,
Dan,
that he's one of those names like Mustapha hom show.
You've got to go.
Oh,
you know what?
Maybe it was.
Maybe it was,
uh,
who'd you say Marvin?
Hagler Ma,
I might be remembering it was,
I think it was,
but I,
I'm not,
I don't remember either.
I feel like Monreal Dan was from a different era.
[inaudible]
Marvin Hagler.
Can Marvin Haggars record such a monster?
Man,
one of my face off.
I thought he thought Roy Jones,
but I could be wrong.
It might be right there.
I don't get early in as Roy John's career could want all down with her anyway.
Oh,
Marvin Hagler Marvin Hagler.
Yeah,
I think that was quite a few years earlier.
Now.
Check uh,
Roy Jones Jr.
Yeah.
One role.
Dan,
let's just keep showing Ron role.
Dan versus Hagler and Hearns different fights.
Yeah,
he fought Hearns too.
Huh?
Thomas Hearns versus Juan role.
Dan,
while enrolled.
Dan was a tough motherfucker,
so it was Mustapha hom show.
There's a lot of tough guys boxing.
It's good right now,
man.
It's great right now.
I saw this was the name Walters Walters versus Sosa.
Bullshit decision though,
man.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I mean blocks and stuff that,
that was a bad decision.
It was really bad.
I was,
I was watching,
I was like this doesn't even make sense.
How the fuck did that happen?
And Max Kellerman was like,
what the fuck are we doing?
Where do you fit a watching and the main your in your schedule,
like where does it go?
How do you guys retain all this?
You must be watching these fights at least twice,
right?
It depends on what the fights like obviously I do it for a living.
So the UFC gym watches,
right?
I watched the,
I watched the Cowboy dos Anjos fight three times.
Okay.
Yeah.
I just wanted to watch it again because I was just so impressed.
I'm so,
he's just such a destroyer.
Like the way he unquote like the combination that he threw when he had cowboy
hurt up against the cage.
Nasty and tight.
Like no,
it's what,
no wild stupid shit controls just controlled aggression.
Just super so super aggressive.
Super fast guys.
You see get home wild cause she didn't finish it.
He stayed composed.
Beat the fuck man.
You guys are on top of boxing too.
Well I watched this last night.
I came home last night and I watched the fight,
man.
Yeah,
I recorded everything.
I watch a lot of fights.
Kickboxing.
I'm deep in.
That's my favorite shit.
My favorite show.
His glory.
This is my favorite shit to watch right now is my favorite right now.
More than MMA.
No,
no,
no.
Come on.
No,
no,
no.
The fuck are you guys talking about MMA is 100% number one of other shit.
What?
I should have clarified that other shit.
Glory is my favorite.
Oh,
boxing.
Okay.
Rico Verhoeven.
Did you see as a his last fight?
The Monster Lord do it.
He's a motherfucker.
He's a motherfucker dude.
And for guys like,
like standup,
you like only watching like,
like get mad when UFC fights go to the ground.
Watch glory.
Watch that man.
Those fucking fights or barn burners.
They are good to me.
There's just so many matches to make him box.
There's so much good shit.
Yeah.
About tans.
Crawford.
Watch that dude.
Yeah man.
Good Lord.
Good God.
Damn that dude's good.
Woo.
Really good.
He's such a good adjuster to adjust in fights and switches.
Stance is really well from Orthodox to southpaw.
You see his last fight?
Yeah.
As soon as he realized he switched southpaw and caught that dude with a right
hook.
It's like,
oh,
we're going to be fighting like this from now on,
sir.
Yeah,
man.
This beat the fuck out of the dude is a brass.
Yeah.
Close fight in the beginning of the first round until he found the rhythm and
then figured it out and I said,
oh,
I'll just switch stances up on this.
He thought he was going to get a mega fight next against Floyd or something.
They're all scared of him.
Nobody wants that.
No one wants to buy and fuck that.
Nobody knows who he is outside of Nebraska.
Everybody in Nebraska knows who he is.
A lot of hardcore boxing fans know who he is.
Yes,
but like the average Joe on the street,
the average person they know Floyd Mayweather is and it'll pack hours.
That's the next fight.
I guarantee.
I guarantee you I'm going to make a prediction.
This is my prediction.
In April they're going to fight again.
I saw pictures of Manny Pacquiao.
He's trip back to training again.
Many pack y'all on his Instagram page.
Today's hitting pads.
So he had a shoulder surgery.
They probably shot him up with the same shit they shot me up with.
He probably healed 50% quicker.
They fucking stem cells.
I know a lot of dudes are doing that now.
I've ever since.
I,
um,
got my stem cell shots and I started talking to him about it.
Swear by it.
A bunch of other people started talking to me about stem cells to,
yeah,
look at Manny Pacquiao shoulder surgery a few months ago.
He's full blast and Charles Manz ads.
Full blast power punching on pads now man,
come on.
That's what you're supposed to wait like a year.
Probably Joost.
Thankfully they probably whacked on what?
The secret sauce,
the secret sauce that only a fix you up when you're talking about a big mess and
they ain't got no,
this ain't the UFC bitch ain't no drug test.
Test and son not in between.
That's one of the beautiful things about these guys too.
In between camp.
Like they get injured.
That's what steroids are for.
Boom.
What's what they're for.
They're supposed to get you back out there quicker.
Do for football player or um,
any sort of an athlete in another sport that doesn't get tested outside of
seasons.
You're supposed to do steroids.
They make you look at it.
He's back.
A little tiny baby scar to tea.
They think of you a little baby scars.
Now they go,
that's a lot of filtering jack.
That's Photoshop,
Bro.
I can put my head on that.
They're going to put a Eddie Bravo was head on that tonight.
Guaranteed.
Hey,
question.
When you had that goatee,
good luck honey.
Dick in the fans and doe.
Floyd.
Man,
it's going to happen.
There's my nowhere.
Nowhere.
I may be wrong.
I'm wrong about a lot of shit,
but here's my prediction.
They're in to open up that new arena in April,
the new arena in Vegas and in April they're going to,
they're going to have a Floyd Mayweather,
Manny Pacquiao dose I lot shit.
I like it.
I think I'll buy the five thing.
I think Floyd Mayweather starts talking.
It's right now it's December.
I think he starts talking somewhere around January,
the end of January.
I like start saying,
you know what I'm thinking about coming back.
And then he hunting Dick's,
Terrence Crawford and Canelo Alvarez and everybody else hunting digsau cause
Canelo Alvarez little cool dude.
He little good against Miguel.
Cotto good.
You look good.
And I thought it looked real good.
Codos a motherfucker,
dude.
He's a crafty,
he's older.
He's still very good.
Yeah,
I think,
uh,
and then Manny Pacquiao,
you know,
they start going over the fact that he got the shoulder surgery and they show
him hitting the pants to get everybody to believe again.
He starts talking about Jesus.
He says all,
he starts doing the cross thing and everybody's like,
you have a chance.
The first time,
the first time he was injured,
I'm that guy.
They can get me.
I watched
one countdown show I am and take my hundred dollars.
You know what I like?
I liked the ones with Max Kellerman when they sit him across the table and then
make them talk to each other,
they soft.
Those are my favorite.
And Max Kellerman says like,
he said that you are this like you.
He said you have no chin.
How do you respond to that?
And then it's usually some dude's speak in Spanish,
this motherfucker and they say say it in Spanish like ac Slater with the chair
backwards steering each other.
It's sick.
Those are great.
I love those.
Those are fun ma'am.
The UFC needs to do something like that.
Oof.
Well that's the thing we're talking about like Nate Diaz and Conor,
I think Eddie's got the best idea to eat glass phone.
Any problems.
Got It.
Right.
No prison glass with a phone or through [inaudible] and gentlemen.
Joey hosting.
No.
Yeah,
but the problem with three giant dudes in between them,
it's not good and I might still sucker punched him.
That's going to hype the fight up even more at DC.
John Jones,
why are you against this?
Why are you against it?
What do you like better?
Do you like animals?
I kind of like your prison glass even better.
You can't sell breaking.
That'd be breaking the fucking phone and shit.
They have to have a tech like a bunch of them.
Maybe a bunch of booze
or the cage.
Just put a fence up.
We'll leave the Joe Silva told Nate Diaz the Conor McGregor is next or do you
think that Nate Diaz is being real smart and talking some shit and getting
people show silver as a smart guy?
He knows damn well I didn't have the power to make that fun.
You know damn well
please.
Danny goes,
Huh?
That's not the fight.
All right.
Dana,
probably text him.
Did you tell him that joke,
right?
No,
I didn't sir.
What?
What Bob Buck Ninja versus Ninja Dss.
UFC match.
Yeah.
That's what we just said.
I just don't,
I don't,
I don't see him doing that.
I think Nate's being smart.
I think he's talking shit and gets great.
I think he's talking shit talking shit that should,
who?
Frankie Edgar.
He should be.
He did.
He said,
he said,
if you're scared,
get a dog.
Yeah,
I saw that.
You gotta.
You gotta be relentless though.
You know what I'm saying?
I know.
I guess it's not his style.
It's not as thought was fighting should speak for itself,
but that's not the type,
that's not the game plan.
Now I feel like there's only one fight to make it further.
Wait,
there's only one fight.
It's 100% Frankie Edgar hundred percent.
I couldn't,
couldn't be more emphatic about that,
but fucking as a fan.
That's what I'm saying.
As a fan,
I don't mind this fucking Nate Diaz fight.
I know I,
and I love Frankie.
I want Frankie to get the shot.
12 frank,
if you're the king,
what do you do it?
If I'm screwing me up,
Dana,
like all the fucking calls,
but no,
I'm dating.
I'm not knowing.
I mean,
I don't even mean,
I don't even mean you're not even Dana because Dana has talked to Lorenzo.
Okay.
What if you are,
you're just the king.
You're the king.
What's the call,
ma'am?
You get in trouble here.
But if I'm trying to get,
if I'm trying to sell the fight,
I want as much money possible.
It's Diaz Conor on a world tour.
But if I'm a good man and I have morals,
I make Frankie Edgar,
uh,
Tanner,
and then the winner that fights Josie.
Well,
when Josie gets healthy,
here's the question though.
Can they tell Connor who to fight now or as Connor?
So meteoric,
hazy,
so out of control as he,
so off the charts would have,
Connor says,
I want to be a promoter,
would have,
Connor says he wants to go money team.
He wants a coat.
Promote and do like he has the power.
He almost does.
He does.
Does he?
80,000 Dublin.
What?
Oh,
he could tell that out in about a minute.
Literally a minute.
A minute.
Yeah.
It sounds like Ron is,
nobody was going to ruin their credit card information.
And then at the stroke of midnight,
1159,
they're all going to press enter the same time.
The computer's going to overload.
All the servers are going to crash.
I for reals,
I'm terrified to fly because I says I'm fucking,
I'm there buying it front row.
Fucking what I'll do.
You'd be my guest.
You'd have to come.
It'd be amazing.
Congress has the power to.
If they go,
we want to fight dos Anjos he goes,
Nah,
I'm good.
Notorious Promotions.
He's going to,
he's going to have his own fight and the Torres Koto Aria.
Yeah.
Look man,
I don't know.
He can't for the sport.
Here's what's,
here's what's crazy.
It's almost like he can't get any bigger.
So what happens now?
Does he just go v since you go parallel?
Cause he just keeps staying the whole time.
Fucking saint enough Hollywood going,
come in.
I want to do final fucking furious fast.
Come here.
Let's fuck your career and he's going to ruin it to put you in fucking
transformer.
13 next thing you know,
he's dating black chicks with big juicy acids and a lot of jewelry.
Dododo does.
That sounds awesome.
That sounds ideal.
And he's driving a Mustang off the top of it.
It's a fucking crazy moving.
Hopefully sewn isn't as aired.
Tell him it's fun.
It's a fun time.
It's fun time to be an MMA fan,
that's for sure.
Especially if you're Conor McGregor.
If I'm scrooge MCDUCK,
I'm the king of the world.
I make the Frankie Edgar fight,
or at least I make an attempt to,
I don't know how much influence they have over him,
but what I would say is I would say honestly your future probably as 155 pounds.
He struggled to make one 45 but your legacy will be complete if you beat frank.
What if common goes one 45 too tough for me.
I haven't found any band band and the hundred 45 pound title and move up and
fight who?
Josie Aldo meets Frankie Edgar rematch.
Okay.
For the title.
I like that.
And um,
Frankie or,
and then Nate Diaz.
Then you have Nate Diaz versus Conor.
It's first fight at 55 if he gets past Nate Diaz,
you 100% having fight dos Anjos correct.
Dos Anjos fight to be remembered.
Madoff.
In the meantime,
if it,
why not?
Is it fun for every he's been injured.
That's true.
If anything,
Tony Ferguson.
Exactly.
Don't forget about Tony Ferguson.
Dos Anjos.
That's a motherfucker.
That's true.
Especially on the Fargo is a fight.
What about Tony Versus Cowboy?
It's already,
they already made it look at that.
Damn.
They Photoshop do's don't fuck around him.
Hell No.
That's legit.
Too quick.
No Holy Shit.
Fans around.
Give the guy credit,
whoever,
whoever the guy was he fine with the guy was oh snap listening his name.
Say just casual casual.
It's can't hear Mommy's on TV.
That's your motto with the titties.
Get on TV.
Yeah,
that's my message boards.
Awesome message boards filled barbarians.
Really their animals in a good way.
Yeah.
Um,
oh what was I gonna say?
Uh,
okay.
So Tony Ferguson,
you have fight dos Anjos snacks.
Totally agree with that.
Yeah.
Great fight.
Great man.
Like for the money though,
the real big money fight for dos Anjos is obviously Connor,
but outside of Connor,
who's a big money fight,
Habib,
we don't even know when he'll be,
he was going to be back.
Right.
So do you have to give,
give Habib uh,
uh,
fight against the top guy before he gets a title shot to fight again.
Okay.
So if so,
who do you give him?
God,
Tony Ferguson.
Cause they were supposed to fight,
right?
Who's Pettis fighting again?
Pedis is finding someone
that's on the Fox card.
The FX fs one in Boston?
Correct.
Wow.
That's Ben Saunders.
Patrick co-tenants.
Right.
I'll be there.
I was going to be in Boston for Boston.
Yup.
I get there on site.
That's a motherfucker.
That's a,
that's a weird weekend for me.
I'm not there for the Wayans.
I've got um,
Atlanta,
a theater in Atlanta and then the theater in Tampa and then I fly into Boston.
You,
you don't another fight that could sell like hotcakes at 55,
Connor and pedis pedis gets by Alvarez.
Boy,
that's a,
that's another blockbuster.
There's so many blockbuster.
That's a good fight.
That's a good fight for um,
pedes versus a Connor is a good fight as far as like styles and on paper and
stuff.
I think that's a really good fight.
But man,
it's a tough sell.
After Namaka Madoff or after a dos Anjos rather beat up pedis pedis has got to
get a victory under his belt in order to,
he gets,
let's say,
get,
gets a head kick,
Kol like,
Oh shit.
Yeah.
If he beats him like he beat Lowe's on or something like that.
Or Cowboy in Japan.
Yeah.
I mean look,
pedes when he loses,
usually comes back away.
Better fighter.
And then that's what happened when he fucked like Weda Click,
we'd have stuffed him,
shut them down.
He came back a way better pedis,
one of my favorite fighters to watch ever.
He's spectacular.
Fucking ridiculous.
Why did they separate the prelims and the main card of it's on the same channel?
Um,
just so that people can time it so that it's like there's two different blocks
of shows.
So instead of having a six hour block of fights,
um,
they have a two,
three hour blocks.
In this case it seems like less than that.
It seems like two hours,
cause it's only four fights in four fights.
First of all,
you have Felder,
verse Kruk Shawl,
crank Shell at the Frank Sean Crookshank Cruickshank the Detroit superstars.
That's a mother fucking great fights son.
That's your fight of the night on that card.
Well,
you know another candidate,
Ross Pearson versus a Francis coach.
Rinaldo.
I'm not mad at that,
but that's a good fucking fight right there.
Otay Sanders,
this card stack Saunders.
Ben Saunders.
Eddie Bravo student.
How dare you saw it was a bad motherfucker to ties him off that,
that dude's a bad motherfucker.
Has that name.
Was he fighting?
Yeah.
He's,
he's nasty man.
Dude rose over back Tyson some.
Have you seen that guy fight?
He's um,
he trains out of a Pooh cat.
He's one of those.
Um,
when the Russians,
yeah.
Um,
uh,
tiger Muay Thai.
He's a tiger Muay Thai guy.
Bladder Russians.
Right to take over.
It's begun to mention,
I think we're at a time.
Are we out of time to that card's a mother fucker,
mother fucker.
So it was time.
That was three hours.
We're talking about fights for 20 minutes.
We talked about sharks for an hour.
We talked about Kurt Cobain for two hours and the fights for 30 seconds.
We're talking about if it's the CIA killed John Lennon and uh,
we've made a few steroid out allegations.
Just,
we tried it,
we cleared it up.
We want to get the MMA media and give him some fruit.
There's your headline's a little hose.
Can I get out of everybody?
We love you.
See you.